Hosting provided by HostTornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode number 10. JavaScript. Take it away, Jason. So, welcome to the valley, Patrick. Yeah. script take it away jason so welcome to the valley patrick yeah uh part of the delay for this episode has been i've been moving yeah so moved out here so for dedication out of dedication
由HostTornado提供主机托管服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第10期。JavaScript。Jason，开始吧。那么，欢迎来到硅谷，Patrick。是的。Jason，开始吧。那么，欢迎来到硅谷，Patrick。是的，呃，这一期节目推迟的部分原因是我一直在搬家，是的，搬到这里来了，所以出于奉献精神，出于奉献精神
for the podcast patrick has decided there's you know it was a hard for us to do the podcast in different time zones you know patrick would have to stay up really late or i'd have to leave work early um and so out of dedication to you guys that's right and for no other reason Patrick decided to move took one for the team that's right 2600 miles to uh Silicon Valley so and this is the big 10 the big one zero congratulations that's right if I had had a streamer, I would blow it. So there goes our clean rating. So, yeah, not too much. Been actually learning a ton of JavaScript and HTML and the whole works.
为了这个播客，Patrick决定了，你知道，我们在不同的时区做播客对我们来说很难，你知道，Patrick必须熬夜很晚，或者我必须早点下班，嗯，所以出于对你们的奉献，没错，而且没有其他原因，Patrick决定搬家，为团队做出了牺牲，没错，2600英里来到呃硅谷，这是第10期，大数字10，恭喜，没错，如果我有彩带，我会吹响它。所以我们那纯洁的评级就这么没了。所以，是的，没太多别的。实际上一直在学习大量的JavaScript和HTML以及所有相关的东西。
How apropos. Yeah, that's right. So feel pretty prepared to come in and nail this podcast uh so what about you so do you have all your stuff yet or no uh no i still don't have all my stuff yet although i did want to make a corollary to your statement from our previous podcast about moving being like defragging okay your hard drive i feel like uh moving is like reformatting your hard drive because i feel like i am getting rid of a ton of stuff that i just decided i don't need anymore like whoa i didn't even know i still had this and you kind of get excited and you're like wait if i went you know x number of years in my case like four years without knowing
真贴切。是的，没错。所以感觉准备得很充分，可以来录制这期播客了，呃，那你呢，你的东西都拿到了吗，还是没有？呃，没有，我还没拿到我所有的东西，虽然我确实想对你上一期播客中关于搬家就像碎片整理的说法做一个推论，好吧，你的硬盘，我觉得呃搬家就像格式化你的硬盘，因为我觉得我正在摆脱一大堆我决定不再需要的东西，就像哇，我甚至不知道我还有这个，你会有点兴奋，你会想，等等，如果我过了，你知道，X年，在我的情况下是四年，不知道
that i had the thing and never used it in four years i could probably do without it yeah i had this like weird almost like buddhist like revelation because i moved and my stuff was uh in storage for a while i want to say like a month or so and and my wife and i realized we really don't need that much stuff and when our stuff did appear i mean of course you know we needed like a bed and things like that like a lot of this stuff we just you know gave to salvation army or something because it was like we just realized you don't need that much to you know be content yeah yeah yeah i don't know that we're you know getting rid of it just to to get down in
我有这个东西，而且四年里从来没用过，我可能不需要它了。是的，我有一种奇怪的、几乎像佛教徒一样的启示，因为我搬家了，我的东西呃在仓库里放了一段时间，我想大概一个月左右，然后我和我妻子意识到我们真的不需要那么多东西，当我们的东西出现时，我的意思是当然，你知道，我们需要一张床之类的东西，但很多东西我们只是，你知道，捐给了救世军之类的，因为我们意识到你不需要那么多东西来，你知道，感到满足。是的，是的，我不知道我们是否，你知道，只是为了减少
size but definitely you know a place we're moving into is smaller so we got to get rid of some stuff but it's always hard because there's some amount of things. It's like this has value to me, but it doesn't necessarily have value to other people. Yeah. And so like you hate just getting rid of it. But so you like I'm giving stuff to my friends and family, you know, you could like sell it to them. But ultimately, you know, it only the value is really what it has to you to give it to somebody else. Like, you know, trophies from high school. It's like, oh, oh these are nice these represent something but i i don't need a hundred of them you want to hear a funny story we uh uh we went to a garage sale my family and i one time this is when i was really young and this person was selling all of their trophies and they actually had a family of like it was like
尺寸而摆脱它们，但肯定，你知道，我们搬进去的地方更小，所以我们必须处理掉一些东西，但这总是很难，因为有一些东西。就像这对我来说有价值，但不一定对别人有价值。是的。所以你讨厌只是扔掉它。但你就像我把东西给我的朋友和家人，你知道，你可以把它们卖给他们。但最终，你知道，它的价值实际上只是它对你来说的价值，把它给别人。就像，你知道，高中的奖杯。就像，哦，哦，这些很好，它们代表了什么，但我不需要一百个。你想听一个有趣的故事吗？我们呃呃有一次去参加车库拍卖，我和我的家人，那是我还很小的时候，这个人正在卖他们所有的奖杯，他们实际上有一个家庭，就像是
wife and husband and they had a family like seven kids that all just graduated or they weren't they didn't all graduate high school but they were all around that age and so they all had a just a ton of they literally had boxes full of trophies and we we bought all of them for like i think you know two dollars or something and then anytime we did anything we got a trophy so we put duct tape over all of them so like one time uh i think like my cousin he was really young he's a baby and he had just like got potty trained and he gave him like a basketball trophy it was totally awesome so every time you made a made a free throw on your ymca team yay here's a trophy yeah that's right your first shot. Your first made shot. Yeah, and nothing would ever match.
妻子和丈夫，他们有一个七个孩子的家庭，都刚毕业，或者他们没有都高中毕业，但他们都在那个年龄左右，所以他们都有很多，他们真的有装满奖杯的盒子，我们我们买了所有这些，大概花了，我想你知道，两美元左右，然后每当我们做了什么事，我们就拿一个奖杯，所以我们在所有奖杯上都贴了胶带，所以有一次呃我想我表弟，他很小，他还是个婴儿，他刚学会用便盆，他给了他一个篮球奖杯，这太棒了，所以每次你在你的基督教青年会球队投进一个罚球，耶，给你一个奖杯，是的，没错，你的第一次投篮。你的第一次进球。是的，而且没有什么能比得上。
I won a spelling bee in fourth grade, and they didn't give us any trophies or anything, but my mom gave me a bowling trophy. Nice. It was pretty epic. But yeah, you realize... But it was even more epic because bowling was the word that won the spelling bee. Oh, that's right.
我在四年级赢了一场拼写比赛，他们没有给我们任何奖杯之类的东西，但我妈妈给了我一个保龄球奖杯。不错。这真是太史诗了。但是，是的，你意识到……但它更史诗，因为“保龄球”是赢得拼写比赛的那个词。哦，没错。
You realize that there are things like that where it's like it has some sentimental value. And then there's almost like you don't want to throw it away, but not really because you care, like because that's sentimental value, but just you don't want to lose something. I don't know what it is, but... Yeah, you can't ever get it back.
你意识到有这样的事情，它有一些情感价值。然后几乎就像你不想扔掉它，但不是因为你在乎，就像因为那是情感价值，而只是你不想失去某样东西。我不知道那是什么，但是……是的，你永远无法找回它。
Yeah, that's right. That's right. And plus it's like you just like the thing you were doing so like i got a trophy for uh playing soccer i got like a participation award because as you might imagine you know patrick and i have very little athletic ability and so for yourself except for your weightlifting olympics i forgot about that that's right that's right but uh but yeah so so my participation awards, you know, it's just, like, I like doing that and playing sports as a little kid and stuff. So I hate to give that stuff up. Yeah.
是的，没错。没错。而且加上它就像你只是喜欢你正在做的事情，所以我因为踢足球得到了一个奖杯，我得到了一个参与奖，因为正如你可能想象的那样，你知道，Patrick和我的运动能力很差，所以对于你自己，除了你的举重奥林匹克，我忘了那个，没错，没错，但是呃，但是是的，所以所以我的参与奖，你知道，这只是，就像，我喜欢做那个，小时候踢运动之类的。所以我讨厌放弃那些东西。是的。
Yeah. And it's hard for me, too. I have, like, a bunch of cool, like, RC, remote control airplane type things. Oh, that's right. And it's, like, because we're moving into a smaller place and not going to have lot of space you know like i'm in debates about what to do with it you know and if you're gonna have to throw them away you should at least crash them epically no that stuff you can typically find people who will you know buy it off of you or whatever yeah that's true it's true so all right well anyways news. Yeah. So the first thing I saw, which is kind of a news slash tip thing that I found, this website, CodeAcademy.com, opened up recently.
是的。对我来说也很难。我有一堆很酷的，像遥控飞机之类的东西。哦，没错。而且，就像，因为我们要搬到一个更小的地方，没有很多空间，你知道，就像我在争论该怎么处理它，你知道，如果你不得不扔掉它们，你应该至少史诗般地撞毁它们。不，那些东西你通常可以找到愿意，你知道，从你那里买走的人，或者别的什么。是的，那是真的，那是真的。所以好吧，无论如何，新闻。是的。我看到的第一件事，这是一种新闻/提示的东西，我发现了，这个网站，CodeAcademy.com，最近开放了。
And I went and checked it out. I saw some news stories about it. We'll have to do it in one of our podcasts, some of the places we go for our news. That might be interesting. Yeah, definitely. do in one of our podcasts the some of the places we go for our news that might be interesting yeah definitely anyways so i saw on a couple of those this codeacademy.com and they have um actually relevant to today uh some lessons about javascript i forget how many about 10 maybe um you know different lessons kind of walking you through very beginning programming very interactive kind of see what you're doing and very well done web 2.0 e you know very nice oh nice um and then
我去看了看。我看到了一些关于它的新闻报道。我们必须在我们的一期播客中讨论一下，我们获取新闻的一些地方。那可能会很有趣。是的，绝对。在我们的一期播客中讨论我们获取新闻的一些地方，那可能会很有趣，是的，绝对。无论如何，所以我看到在其中几个网站上提到了这个codeacademy.com，他们有嗯，实际上与今天相关，一些关于JavaScript的课程，我忘了有多少，也许10个，你知道，不同的课程，引导你进行非常基础的编程，非常互动，可以看到你在做什么，而且做得非常好，Web 2.0风格，你知道，非常好，哦，不错，嗯，然后
i saw an article on tech crunch that said that 200 000 people uh used it and did some number 2.1 million lessons on it in just three days which is crazy because this is very niche and not only is it niche that it's a programming site but the fact that it's for like very beginners like you know for you and i is going to be like snooze fest i i don't mean that we're expert programmers sort of like beyond the beginning stage kind of like if someone just told you to bench 200 or something after you did your olympics it would be like somebody telling you to bench 15 and yeah that's right okay anyway sorry so so um i i encourage you guys to check that out code academy.com and that's also
我在Tech Crunch上看到一篇文章说有20万人使用了它，并且在短短三天内完成了210万次课程，这很疯狂，因为这非常小众，而且不仅因为它是一个编程网站，而且它针对的是像非常初学者的人，你知道，对你和我来说会像催眠一样，我不是说我们是专家程序员，有点像超越了初级阶段，就像如果有人在你参加完奥林匹克运动会后让你卧推200磅，那就像有人让你卧推15磅，是的，没错，好吧，无论如何，抱歉，所以嗯，我鼓励你们去看看那个codeacademy.com，而且那也
cool that somebody you know is teaching others to do programming and apparently i assume it's some sort of you know startup or there's some money motivation they're advertising i'm not sure what or if it's just non-for-profit um i don't know but that's kind of encouraging that this guy got that much traction and people signing up and using it or eric could be a lady i don't know but um yeah that's that's pretty awesome and you know i was thinking about that that there's got to be a pretty big market not only to learning programming yourself and making yourself more marketable because that's a growing industry and i can't see any reason why it wouldn't grow even more in the coming years but also if you uh want to teach others who want
很酷，有人，你知道，在教别人编程，显然我假设这是一种，你知道，初创公司，或者有某种金钱动机，他们在做广告，我不确定是什么，或者它是否只是非营利组织，嗯，我不知道，但这有点令人鼓舞，这个人获得了那么多的关注，人们注册并使用它，或者Eric可能是一位女士，我不知道，但嗯，是的，那真的很棒，而且你知道，我在想，一定有一个很大的市场，不仅是学习编程本身，让自己更有市场价值，因为这是一个不断增长的行业，我看不出未来几年它为什么不会增长得更多，而且如果你，你知道，想教那些想
to get in the field of computer science programming that kind of stuff um there could be some it's a win-win right you're getting money to do something that you like teaching others and helping people learn programming kind of like you know something we're doing with this podcast although we're not getting money but if you'd like to donate let us know that's right um and uh or just pay us you know yeah we take checks cash money order credit cards i think that you know one of the things that i've always kind of believed is that everyone should learn how to program like programming should be something that's taught at a fundamental level like every high schooler should know how to program because i feel like any job could be made easier if with knowledge of programming you know and i i won't go
进入计算机科学编程领域的人，那种东西，嗯，可能会有一些双赢，对吧？你因为做你喜欢的事情而得到报酬，教别人并帮助人们学习编程，有点像，你知道，我们正在用这个播客做的事情，虽然我们没有得到报酬，但如果你想捐款，让我们知道，没错，嗯，或者只是付钱给我们，你知道，是的，我们接受支票、现金、汇票、信用卡，我认为，你知道，我一直相信的一件事是，每个人都应该学习如何编程，就像编程应该是在基础层面教授的东西，就像每个高中生都应该知道如何编程，因为我觉得任何工作如果有了编程知识都会变得更容易，你知道，而且我不会走
so far as to say any job but yeah a lot of jobs even if you're just using excel yeah and i mean i'm not even talking about computer programming but the idea of sort of coming up with yeah algorithms are coming up with like a recipe it's sort of like i want to do these things you know there was a game uh at epcot in uh in walt disney world in florida where um i remember when i was really young we went to this uh i i can't remember what it was called but it was an area of epcot where they had like machines from the future which was like you know a 486 dx or something but um they had a game on there where you had a position and there was sort of a grid. And so you're walking around on this grid.
那么远说任何工作，但是的，很多工作，即使你只是在使用Excel，是的，而且我的意思甚至不是计算机编程，而是那种，你知道，想出算法或者想出像食谱一样的东西的想法，它有点像，我想做这些事情，你知道，在佛罗里达州华特迪士尼世界的艾波卡特有一个游戏，嗯，我记得我小时候去过这个，嗯，我记不起它叫什么了，但它是艾波卡特的一个区域，他们有来自未来的机器，就像是，你知道，486 DX之类的，但嗯，他们在上面有一个游戏，你有一个位置，并且有一种网格。所以你在网格上走来走去。
Oh, yeah. Or you have to program a robot how to move to get to a goal. So you put like 2L, 2D, 2R. And that would go two spaces to the left, two down to the right. And so you have to put this really complicated sequence to get you to the goal. And, you know, along the way there's little pitfalls and it would tell you oops, and you'd change your sequence and eventually you'd get it right. And so I'm just talking about programming at that level,
哦，是的。或者你必须编程一个机器人如何移动以到达目标。所以你输入像2L，2D，2R。那就会向左走两格，向下向右走两格。所以你必须输入这个非常复杂的序列才能到达目标。而且，你知道，一路上有小陷阱，它会告诉你“哎呀”，然后你会改变你的序列，最终你会做对。所以我只是在谈论那个层面的编程，
like being able to understand like a sequence of commands and sort of what's going to happen at the end or iteration. And I just feel like any job could benefit you know from knowing something like this yeah the the algorithmic the codifying of a set of things and boiling down and unambiguity yeah i agree yeah i mean like let's say you said for that let's say i mean there's nothing against janitors janitors are awesome people but a lot of people wouldn't consider janitors programmers but let's say you uh excel at being a janitor, and all of a sudden you're a manager, and you're managing a team of janitors to clean an office complex or something. So there's a lot of programming there.
就像能够理解一系列命令以及最后会发生什么，或者迭代。我只是觉得任何工作都可以从知道这样的事情中受益，是的，算法，对一系列事物进行编码，并归纳和消除歧义，是的，我同意，是的，我的意思是，假设你说那个，假设我，我的意思是，没有什么反对清洁工的，清洁工是很棒的人，但很多人不会认为清洁工是程序员，但假设你，呃，擅长做清洁工，突然你成了经理，你正在管理一个清洁工团队来清洁一个办公大楼之类的。所以那里有很多编程。
You have to sort of arrange the schedules. You have to worry about the overlaps. And people, if it takes them— How frequently should you clean? Yeah, and if it takes them 45 minutes to do one area and two hours to do this other area, how can you keep them busy for the whole eight hours? I mean, there's a lot of math, a lot of programming there. And the fact that we don't really teach any programming, it's not compulsory.
你必须安排时间表。你必须担心重叠。还有人，如果他们需要——你应该多久清洁一次？是的，如果他们需要45分钟来做一个区域，需要两个小时来做另一个区域，你怎么能让他们在整整八个小时里都有事做？我的意思是，那里有很多数学，很多编程。而且我们并没有真正教授任何编程的事实，它不是强制性的。
It's just, I don't know, I think it's a little crazy. Huh. Interesting. Yeah. So definitely a space i mean i think it would be a benefit if people have ideas or things they want to do there to to teach others would be good yeah for sure so there's all this craziness about the hp touchpads going to 99 dollars and the other day well the craziness is that the hp touchpad is being discontinued yeah well and hp is in a lot
这只是，我不知道，我觉得这有点疯狂。嗯。有趣。是的。所以绝对是一个空间，我的意思是，我认为如果人们有想法或他们想做的事情来教别人，那会很好，是的，当然，所以关于惠普TouchPad降价到99美元的所有疯狂事情，还有前几天，嗯，疯狂的是惠普TouchPad正在停产，是的，嗯，惠普在很多
of financial hp is is in a ton of trouble. But that isn't necessarily. I mean, people have known that for a while. But I mean, I've never seen anything like this. Like, I mean, when is the last time where some company was in trouble and just ran like a fire sale on all their hardware? Like, even like, you know, when Circuit City closed. I don't know if it's because of regulations or what, but nothing was really discounted very heavily. And in fact, I believe Apple didn't.
财务方面，惠普陷入了巨大的麻烦。但这并不一定。我的意思是，人们已经知道这一点有一段时间了。但我的意思是，我从来没见过这样的事情。就像，我的意思是，上一次有公司陷入困境并对其所有硬件进行清仓大甩卖是什么时候？就像，即使是，你知道，当Circuit City倒闭时。我不知道是因为法规还是什么，但没有什么东西真的被大幅打折。事实上，我相信苹果没有。
You could buy it cheaper online than it was in the store. Yeah, even with the store closing sale. So to see something that's marked at $500 go to $100 is pretty rare, and it causes massive explosion in purchases. So did you yourself want a hundred dollars for a pretty decent tablet seems like a good deal yeah so it runs web os which of course is run by hp so that's pretty much gone and i didn't get one kind of dead end yeah i didn't get one because i thought oh the operating system is not to be kept up to date but this news article uh hp touchpads linux slash android ports on the way shows that you know there's actually going to
你可以在网上买到比店里更便宜的东西。是的，即使有商店倒闭促销。所以看到一个标价500美元的东西降到100美元是非常罕见的，它导致了购买量的巨大爆炸。所以你自己想要一个100美元的相当不错的平板电脑吗？看起来是个不错的交易，是的，所以它运行webOS，当然是由惠普运行的，所以那基本上已经没了，而且我没有买一个，有点死胡同，是的，我没有买，因为我想哦，操作系统不会保持更新，但这条新闻文章，惠普TouchPad Linux/Android端口即将到来，显示出，你知道，实际上会有
be a path forward for these touchpads i'm kind of kicking myself yeah so a couple notes on this since i made the the show notes here that even now there's been some edits some people have offered a bounty so i think it's up to a couple thousand dollars now to the first person who can get android on the web os nice um and then some other people which I I haven't seen if it's a fake or not yet I they were saying it's true, but some people bought touch pads that had Android on them Oh Wow out of the box shrink-wrapped and they boot to like some Qualcomm screen Oh weird, so it's like a Qualcomm Research Center So they don't there's a lot of speculation about what happened and that they might be a really elaborate fraud.
一条前进的道路，这些TouchPad，我有点后悔，是的，所以关于这个有几点说明，因为我在这里做了节目笔记，即使现在已经有一些编辑，有些人提供了赏金，所以我认为现在已经达到几千美元了，给第一个能把Android装进webOS的人，不错，然后还有其他人，我还没看到它是真是假，他们说这是真的，但有些人买了装有Android的TouchPad，哦，哇，开箱即用，塑封的，它们启动到某个高通屏幕，哦，奇怪，所以它就像一个高通研究中心，所以他们不，关于发生了什么有很多猜测，而且它们可能是一个非常复杂的欺诈。
But I watched a video. It seemed pretty convincing, these people turning on Android devices or turning on touchpads and having it boot to Android. And they claim they got them out of the box that way. Yeah, it's awesome. The thing about the iPad, and maybe you own an iPad, right? Or I guess I should say the thing about the tablet. I can never seem to find a use case for the tablet. Like, that's why, you know, I have some, like, oh, I could put recipes on it.
但我看了一个视频。这似乎很有说服力，这些人打开Android设备或打开TouchPad，并让它启动到Android。他们声称他们开箱就是那样。是的，这太棒了。关于iPad的事情，也许你拥有一台iPad，对吧？或者我想我应该说关于平板电脑的事情。我似乎永远找不到平板电脑的用例。就像，这就是为什么，你知道，我有几个，哦，我可以把食谱放在上面。
But, I mean, I don't really have a $400 use case. I mean, what do you use your tablet for? $400, it is hard. It is hard. But I use mine definitely when I travel. It's awesome. So, like, I don't have to take my laptop anymore if I'm only traveling only traveling over like a weekend or, you know, a few days for business or something. For business, I have my business laptop.
但是，我的意思是，我真的没有400美元的用例。我的意思是，你用你的平板电脑做什么？400美元，这很难。这很难。但我旅行时肯定会用我的。这太棒了。所以，就像，如果我只是旅行，只旅行一个周末，或者，你知道，出差几天之类的，我就不必带我的笔记本电脑了。对于工作，我有我的工作笔记本电脑。
But for personal stuff, I just bring my iPad. It's more than enough to check my email, read my webpages, you know, see the news. It's very, very nice. Also use it like if I wake up in the morning early and i'm not ready to get up and get at it yet i'll take on ipad and use it there or at night before going to bed you know because it's a much more portable so that's nice i read it read comics on it use it to play games i have books on there i would like to claim that i read them but to be honest it's really distracting to have it do so much else you find yourself really easily distracted and uh it
但对于个人事务，我只是带我的iPad。检查我的电子邮件，阅读我的网页，你知道，看新闻，这绰绰有余。它非常，非常棒。我也用它，比如如果我早上起得很早，还没准备好起床开始工作，我会拿上iPad在上面用，或者晚上睡觉前，你知道，因为它更便携，所以那很好，我在上面读漫画，用它玩游戏，我在上面有书，我想声称我读了它们，但老实说，让它做这么多其他事情真的很让人分心，你会发现自己很容易分心，而且它
has awesome battery life so i mean it lasts you could use it probably for six seven hours doing stuff on it and before the battery runs out oh that's pretty awesome which a laptop won't do without power yeah i guess i guess it's a smartphone situation all over again i never thought i would use a smartphone and now i'm kind of addicted to it yeah it's hard you really got to personalize it to your taste and have your stuff on it and you know check twitter on it you know whatever it it's you got to have one i used other people's always like i don't get it like this is silly but when it's yours and you have it with you you know it it doesn't make a difference do you have a keyboard or how does that work no they have an on-screen keyboard you can get a bluetooth keyboard for it my some my brother has one okay he uses with it
有很棒的电池寿命，所以我的意思是它能持续，你可能可以在上面用它六七个小时做事情，在电池耗尽之前，哦，那太棒了，笔记本电脑在没有电源的情况下做不到，是的，我想我想这又是智能手机的情况了，我从没想过我会用智能手机，现在我有点上瘾了，是的，这很难，你真的必须根据你的口味个性化它，把你的东西放在上面，你知道，在上面查看Twitter，你知道，无论什么，你必须有一个，我用过别人的，总是像我不明白，就像这很傻，但当它是你的，而且你随身携带它时，你知道，它确实有区别，你有键盘吗，或者它是怎么工作的？不，他们有屏幕键盘，你可以为它买一个蓝牙键盘，我的一些，我兄弟有一个，好吧，他用它
i don't tend to create content on it so that makes sense it's not really a big deal for me but he says it works really well it connects wirelessly oh nice that's pretty awesome so um so talking about the twitter uh something I saw on Twitter that was pretty interesting was the guy who started or first created Minecraft, the head guy, he goes by his handle Notch. His real name is – it's slipping away now. Oh, I'll look it up. Do you know? Okay. But Notch, and I follow him on Twitter, and he posts stuff about working on Minecraft, which is now a company Mojang.
我不倾向于在上面创作内容，所以这说得通，对我来说不是什么大不了的事，但他说它工作得很好，它无线连接，哦，不错，那太棒了，所以嗯，所以谈到Twitter，我在Twitter上看到的一些相当有趣的事情是，那个开始或首先创建Minecraft的人，负责人，他用他的昵称Notch。他的真名是——现在想不起来了。哦，我会查一下。你知道吗？好吧。但是Notch，我在Twitter上关注他，他发布关于开发Minecraft的事情，现在是一家公司Mojang。
His name is Marcus Person. Marcus Person. Okay. I always want to say Mark Pincus, but that's the guy who runs Zynga. Yeah. So their names are kind of close. Anyways, they're both in the games. So, yeah, Marcus, so Notch, you know, has his Twitter feed,
他的名字是Marcus Person。Marcus Person。好吧。我总是想说Mark Pincus，但那是经营Zynga的人。是的。所以他们的名字有点像。无论如何，他们都在游戏中。所以，是的，Marcus，所以Notch，你知道，有他的Twitter订阅，
talks about all this stuff. It's pretty cool. You can follow him. He does pretty interesting stuff um and he would have been you know had the story that he was coming out with a game or had an idea for a game called scrolls and um there is a company in in america i guess it's it's worldwide uh bethesda that is um so they're the people who made Fallout 3, Oblivion Yeah, so they make Elder Scrolls, which is, Oblivion was
谈论所有这些事情。这很酷。你可以关注他。他做一些相当有趣的事情，嗯，他本来会，你知道，有那个故事，他要推出一个游戏，或者有一个叫Scrolls的游戏的想法，嗯，在美国有一家公司，我猜它是全球性的，Bethesda，是，嗯，所以他们是制作Fallout 3、Oblivion的人，是的，所以他们制作Elder Scrolls，这是，Oblivion是
one of the Elder Scrolls series I think, yeah And they're coming out with a new one, even Skyrim I think it's called Yeah, I'm not into those style of RPGs But they have this Elder Scrolls with these different titles in this series, and so
Elder Scrolls系列之一，我想，是的，而且他们要推出一个新的，甚至Skyrim，我想它叫这个，是的，我不喜欢那种风格的RPG，但他们有这个带有这些不同标题的Elder Scrolls系列，所以
they found out he was making a game called scrolls and they decided to sue him yeah i mean he has millions of dollars might as well right i i have no logic behind it i don't think a lot of people get confused between scrolls and elder scrolls um and the games are not similar in any way from their description. So he's been kind of, he was griping about it. And then one day he gets on and basically says he's going to challenge them that instead of making the lawyers rich on both sides, why don't they just
他们发现他正在制作一个叫Scrolls的游戏，他们决定起诉他，是的，我的意思是，他有数百万美元，不妨这样做，对吧？我背后没有任何逻辑，我不认为很多人会混淆Scrolls和Elder Scrolls，而且这些游戏在描述上没有任何相似之处。所以他一直在抱怨。然后有一天他上线，基本上说他要挑战他们，与其让双方的律师发财，为什么他们不只是
settle this? And he agreed that, you know, he claims he's serious about it, that they'll have, you know, and he set up the rules. Basically, they'll play Quake 3, a couple of the guys from his team and him, versus a team that they can pick, you know, and he set up the rules. Basically, they'll play Quake 3, a couple of the guys from his team and him, versus a team that they can pick on their end. They'll play several rounds of Deathmatch of Quake 3. And then whoever wins, if he wins, he gets to call his game Scrolls.
解决这个问题？他同意，你知道，他声称他是认真的，他们会，你知道，而且他制定了规则。基本上，他们会玩Quake 3，他团队里的几个人和他，对抗他们可以挑选的团队，你知道，而且他制定了规则。基本上，他们会玩Quake 3，他团队里的几个人和他，对抗他们可以在他们那边挑选的团队。他们会玩几轮Quake 3的死亡竞赛。然后谁赢了，如果他赢了，他就可以把他的游戏叫Scrolls。
And he's saying either way, he always will plan to, if it would make it any better, that he'll say that, you know, that they're not associated with, you know, Elder Scrolls. That this is its own thing, no way affiliated with Bethesda. And so he says that if he wins, he'll still do that, but he gets to call his name Scrolls. And if he loses, he'll call it something else. Yeah, I think that's awesome. I think good for him for sort of making it,
他说无论哪种方式，他总是计划，如果这能让事情变得更好，他会说，你知道，他们与Elder Scrolls无关。这是它自己的东西，与Bethesda没有任何关联。所以他说如果他赢了，他仍然会那样做，但他可以把他的名字叫Scrolls。如果他输了，他会叫它别的名字。是的，我认为这太棒了。我认为他这样做很好，因为这让他和他的团队获得了更多的宣传，因为这真的是他能从中获得的唯一东西。所以他把一个烂摊子变成了一个机会。他把柠檬变成了柠檬水。在某种程度上，是的。他从中得到了很多宣传。我认为这太棒了。我相信很多人看到了这一点
bringing more publicity to him and his team, because that's really what's the only thing that he can gain out of it. So he sort of took a rotten thing that was offered. He took lemons and made lemonade. In some way, yeah. He got a lot of publicity out of it. I think it's pretty awesome. I'm sure a lot of people saw that
并且真的有点对他说“向你致敬”。是的，但这确实提到了这些事情变得多么愚蠢，你知道，甚至Android手机，Droid，我看到底部，每当有Droid广告时，它说，你知道，基本上给Lucas Films Ltd的一些说明，所以George Lucas的公司，因为Droid是星球大战系列的商标，是的，我的意思是，真的，诉讼已经越来越失控了，嗯，你知道，苹果正在起诉HTC，我相信，还有其他几个Droid，他们现在都在互相起诉，我的意思是，基本上，你知道，这有点像
and really kind of said kudos to him. Yeah, but it does bring up how silly some of this stuff has gotten that you know or even the the android phones the droid i see at the bottom whenever there was a droid commercial it says you know basically some note to lucas films ltd so george lucas's company because droid is a trademark of the star wars series yeah i mean really the lawsuits are just have gotten more and more out of hand um you know apple's suing hcc i believe and like several other droid they're all suing each other at this point i mean basically you know the it's sort of like
冷战，除了它，除了我们已经达到了，那叫什么，是相互保证毁灭吗？是的，但相互，那个词是什么？我一直想说Defcon，我想是Defcon，Defcon是，那就像当你受到威胁时，好吧，Defcon是一个黑客会议，但Defcon也是，嗯，状态，所以有一个Defcon级别，这是冷战时期的，是的，所以如果你处于Defcon级别1，那意味着基本上每个人都在向对方发射核弹，所以当我们谈到专利和专利诉讼时，我们现在处于Defcon级别1，看起来是这样，而且它没有，它没有帮助，没有人因为这个而创新或做更多的工作，只是律师赚了更多的钱，是的
the cold war except it except we've reached uh what was that called is it deaf mutually assured destruction yeah but mutually what's the word for that i keep wanting to say defcon i think it is defcon defcon is that's like when you're under threat well defcon's a hacking conference but defcon's also the um state so there's a defcon level this is back from the cold war yeah and so if you're at defcon level like one then that means basically everyone's launching nukes at each other and so we're at defcon level one right now when it comes to patents and and patent litigation it seems that way and it doesn't it doesn't help nobody's like innovating because of this or doing more work just lawyers are making more money yeah
最糟糕的部分是那些受到打击的人，因为你知道，像HTC和苹果这样的大公司，他们基本上对这些诉讼耸耸肩，或者他们，你知道，所以真正受到重创的是小公司，像某人，Lodsis正在起诉Angry Birds，我们谈到了，是的，所有苹果，他们正在起诉Rovio，制作Angry Birds的公司，就是关于这个。所有苹果。他们正在起诉Rovio，制作Angry Birds的公司。这就像那样的公司可能只是地下室里的五个人，对吧？我的意思是，他们负担不起。哦，Rovio。
and the worst part is the people who get hit because you know huge companies like HTC and and Apple and things like that they basically shrug these lawsuits off or they you know so so the people who really get hit hard are the small companies like somebody Lodsis was suing Angry Birds we talked about yeah all the Apple they were suing Roxio the company that makes Angry Birds and it's about this. All the Apple. They were suing Roxio, the company that makes Angry Birds. And it's like a company like that is probably just five guys in their basement, right? I mean, they can't afford. Oh, Rovio.
哦，是Rovio。他们负担不起大公司的诉讼。好吧，实际上，Angry Birds的开发者可能负担得起。真的吗？也许。到现在，是的。我的意思是，Angry Birds很大，但我不认为它像HTC那么大。你知道我的意思吗？
Oh, it's Rovio. They can't afford to take a lawsuit from a huge company. Well, actually, the Angry Birds developers probably can. Really? Maybe. By now, yeah. I mean, Angry Birds is big, but I don't think it's like HTC big. You know what I mean?
不，是的，我不知道。但我的意思是，无论如何，是的，很多小开发者只是因为这些专利而被殴打。这太荒谬了。所以当我们谈论游戏时，我想你应该讲这个故事。没关系。不用担心。所以新的Deus Ex刚刚出来。是的，Deus Ex Human Revolution出来了，是的，Deus Ex Human Revolution
No, yeah, I don't know. But I mean, regardless, yeah, a lot of little developers are just getting beat up over these patents. It's just ridiculous. So while we're on games, I guess you were supposed to do this story. That's okay. No worries. So the new Deus Ex has just come out. Yeah, Deus Ex Human Revolution come out yeah Deus Ex Human Revolution
实际上Deus Ex，你玩过吗？嗯，没有，但Deus Ex，Deus Ex 1载入史册，它是我有史以来最喜欢的游戏之一
actually Deus Ex have you played it? well no but Deus Ex Deus Ex 1 is goes down in history it was one of my favorite games of all time
真的吗？我的意思是，我以前玩过，但我从来没有玩过很长时间，是的，所以有几件事让它变得很棒，一个是
really? I mean I played it before but I didn't ever play it for very long yeah so there's a number of things that make it awesome one is
这个关于意识的整个哲学讨论，你知道，你，他们有点走在什么是意识和不是什么的边界上，游戏背后有整个哲学潜台词，你知道，实际上根据你的观点，你知道，比如机器人，人形机器人有多有意识之类的，你实际上可以改变结局，所以你知道，实际上我回去玩了它，我
this whole like philosophical you know discussion of consciousness and you know you're they're sort of walking the boundary between what's conscious and not there's like this whole philosophical undertone and you know behind the game and actually depending on your opinion you know of like how conscious a robot is a humanoid robot and things like that you can actually change the ending so you know actually i went back and played it and i
总是尝试像诚实地回答，你知道，除非我把游戏又玩了一遍，但这次我回答得很诚实，而且自从我，你知道，13岁或者它出来的时候，我的观点，关于意识、机器人技术之类的，已经改变了，不，我不知道，也许16岁左右，所以嗯，我实际上有一个不同的结局，你知道，这只是，那太迷人了。而且它也有很多游戏元素。比如你有不同的技能。所以如果你专注于潜行技能，那么你可以做非常酷的任务，比如你甚至不需要杀任何人。你只是使用潜行并避开所有人。
always try and like answer truthfully you know unless i've played the game you know over again but this time i went through answer truthfully and i've my opinions as far as you know consciousness robotics and things have changed since i since i was like 13 or wherever it came out no i don't know maybe like 16 and so um i actually had a different ending, you know, and it was just, that was like fascinating. And it also has a lot of sort of gamey elements. Like you have different skills. So if you focus on the stealthy skills, then you could do like really cool missions where like you don't even like kill anybody. You just use stealth and avoid everyone.
如果你专注于军事技能，那么你可以发射火箭并炸毁人们，所以它真的为每个人提供了一些东西，嗯，所以我真的很兴奋玩新的，第三个，但是的，我还没玩过，所以它要出来了，还有另一家公司，我还没试过，你在Live上试过吗？不，我听说过它，我，我实际上，我不相信，但我从我信任的人那里听说过关于它的好消息，是的，是的，所以我，我实际上，我不相信，但我从我信任的人那里听说过关于它的好消息，是的，是的，所以我
If you focus on like the military skills, then you can shoot rockets and just blow people up so it really kind of has something for everybody um so i'm really excited to play the new one the third one but yeah i haven't done it yet so it's coming out and there's this other company which is i have not tried it have you tried it yet on live no i've heard of it i i've actually i didn't believe it but i've heard really good things about it from people i trust yeah yeah so i'm've actually i didn't believe it but i've heard really good things about it from people i trust yeah yeah so i'm thinking i'm gonna have to check it out so basically on live has and correct me if if this is wrong but the way i understand is they have servers that basically run games for you so you've got a very high-end game that takes a lot of processing power
想我得去看看。所以基本上OnLive有，如果我说错了请纠正我，但我理解的方式是，他们有基本上为你运行游戏的服务器，所以你有一个非常高端的游戏，需要大量的处理能力
expensive graphics cards these kinds of things so like deus ex or crisis 2 or you know any other game that is is really you know high-end graphics that kind of stuff and they run it on their server and then they basically you know most are kind of like a remote it amounts to kind of like a remote desktop thing where your controls get fed into the server the game runs and then they stream the video back to you the video and audio and so you end up not running very much processing on your computer and it's just network activity and they even sell now i think a little box that handles the you know just taking the inputs and displaying the output so you know equivalent of like a roku box or a boxy box
昂贵的显卡，这些东西，比如Deus Ex或Crisis 2，或者你知道，任何其他，你知道，高端图形之类的游戏，他们在他们的服务器上运行它，然后他们基本上，你知道，大多数有点像远程，它相当于一种远程桌面，你的控制被输入到服务器，游戏运行，然后他们把视频流回给你，视频和音频，所以你最终不会在你的电脑上运行太多的处理，它只是网络活动，他们甚至现在卖，我想一个小盒子，处理，你知道，只是接收输入和显示输出，所以你知道，相当于Roku盒子或Boxee盒子
or a google tv box or you uh you know size of like maybe a i don't know really small thing you can play games on your tv or on a computer screen and i've heard it works really well and the nice thing is it's it's fairly expensive you it's like buying the game at full price and i don't think it's any uh ongoing expenses but then they host the game and you can play it whenever you want yeah i mean it's pretty awesome you don't have to shell out 400 for the latest console um yeah or a new computer yeah um and so they were putting codes the way i understand it is at least in the beginning shipments they were putting codes for a free license on on live for this deus ex if you bought
或Google TV盒子，或者你，你知道，大小像也许我不知道，非常小的东西，你可以在你的电视或电脑屏幕上玩游戏，我听说它工作得很好，而且好的一点是它相当昂贵，你，它就像以全价购买游戏，而且我不认为有任何持续的费用，但然后他们托管游戏，你可以随时玩，是的，我的意思是，这太棒了，你不必为最新的游戏机掏出400美元，嗯，是的，或者一台新电脑，是的，嗯，所以他们正在放置代码，我理解的方式是，至少在最初的装运中，他们正在为这个Deus Ex放置OnLive的免费许可证代码，如果你买了
the deus ex in a box store um so that's a really great you know thing like if you buy it and you'll have it but gamestop is very threatened by online delivery you know things like steam and on live and others that are not people don't have to go to the store and buy a box they just go online and buy it and they trust it and there's all sorts of drm issues we could get into about why that might not be the best thing that industry is moving that way. But this is the way it's moving. And so GameStop is very threatened by this. And they're trying to get into digital distribution to counter it.
盒装店里的Deus Ex，所以那是一个非常棒的，你知道，事情，比如如果你买了它，你就会拥有它，但GameStop非常受到在线交付的威胁，你知道，像Steam和OnLive以及其他人，人们不必去商店买盒子，他们只是上网买它，而且他们信任它，而且有很多DRM问题，我们可以讨论为什么那可能不是最好的事情，行业正在向那个方向发展。但这就是它发展的方向。所以GameStop非常受到这个的威胁。他们正试图进入数字分发来对抗它。
And so all of that swirled up. Basically, they instructed their managers to open the shrink wrap copies of Deus Ex and take out the coupon that had the on live code printed on it that's ridiculous so i guess they had to like re-shrink wrap it then at the store right yeah i i think so but they sell used games so i think they have the you know plastic and the heat gun to do it yeah so that's pretty crazy i i don't know how i feel about that i mean yeah it's pretty it's pretty wild i mean i get the impression that things like this happen all the time but we just found out about this one you know oh maybe and it seems like if i were gamestop like i don't have a problem with gamestop being
所以所有这些都搅在一起了。基本上，他们指示他们的经理打开Deus Ex的塑封副本，取出印有OnLive代码的优惠券，那太荒谬了，所以我猜他们必须在店里重新塑封它，对吧？是的，我想是这样，但他们卖二手游戏，所以我认为他们有，你知道，塑料和热风枪来做这件事，是的，所以那太疯狂了，我不知道我对此感觉如何，我的意思是，是的，这太疯狂了，我的意思是，我有一种印象，这样的事情一直都在发生，但我们只是发现了这一个，你知道，哦，也许，而且看起来如果我是GameStop，就像我不反对GameStop
opposed to it but they should have worked with i don't know who makes deus ex but they should have worked with that company and said look we really want the ones that come to us to not have the coupon in it and then they could have just done that for them. And then I wouldn't have had a problem with it. I just don't like the fact that they, like, opened it up and removed it. Yeah, they probably didn't know until it was too late or something. But, yeah, I mean, it's pretty shady, I mean, to tamper with the device before giving it to the customers, you know. I mean, the worst part is if if you know people are going to
反对它，但他们应该与，我不知道是谁制作Deus Ex，但他们应该与那家公司合作，说看，我们真的希望发给我们的是没有优惠券的，然后他们就可以为他们那样做了。然后我就不会有问题了。我只是不喜欢他们，你知道，打开它并移除它的事实。是的，他们可能直到太晚了才知道，或者别的什么。但，是的，我的意思是，这太阴暗了，我的意思是，在给客户之前篡改设备，你知道。我的意思是，最糟糕的部分是如果，如果你知道人们会
know that oh the game comes with this thing and so if they buy and it doesn't come with it you know they're going to get upset like the customers yeah and you're going to drive away your customers because here is like a reason to actually go to a box store and buy it and not just download it from you know steam or wherever and now you go and it's like oh i'm getting the same treatment well forget that i'm not doing that anymore yeah i think that it's only a matter of time before steam kind of takes over it's like you know with portal 3 or sorry portal 2 i think it's oh you heard it here first yeah that's right secrets out i think that like if I remember correctly...
知道哦，游戏附带了这个东西，所以如果他们买了，而它没有附带，你知道，他们会生气的，就像客户一样，是的，而且你会赶走你的客户，因为这里有一个理由去盒装店买它，而不是只是从，你知道，Steam或任何地方下载它，现在你去买，就像哦，我得到了同样的待遇，好吧，忘了它，我不再那样做了，是的，我认为Steam接管只是时间问题，就像，你知道，Portal 3，或者抱歉，Portal 2，我想是，哦，你在这里第一次听说，是的，没错，秘密泄露了，我想如果我没记错的话……
Oh, no, it was backwards. If you bought the PlayStation copy of Portal 2, you also got the Steam copy. But really, that would have been nice to go the other way, where if you bought it on Steam, you also got to download it for the PS3. If they had done that, I think that would have been the beginning of the end
哦，不，它是反过来的。如果你买了Portal 2的PlayStation副本，你也得到了Steam副本。但真的，如果能反过来会很好，如果你在Steam上买了它，你也可以下载它到PS3。如果他们那样做了，我想那将是终结的开始
for GameSpot, you know, GameStop. Yeah, it could have been. It's hard to say i mean like i said with the drm i actually don't necessarily like the steam thing because well steam you don't pay a subscription for so it's not as bad but i mean if they one day run out of money and stop having it and if they just turn off the license servers for all of your games six months later you're not gonna be able to play games anymore yeah all the games you bought yeah definitely and i still have games i was when i was packing i saw games that i had from you know before 2000 1995 1999 you know all these awesome old school games playing the x-com thing no i don't have them that far okay but you know like uh maybe they're like the original starcraft i don't have them that far. Oh, okay. But, you know, like maybe the original StarCraft.
对于GameSpot，你知道，GameStop。是的，这可能是。很难说，我的意思是，就像我说的，关于DRM，我实际上不一定喜欢Steam的东西，因为，好吧，Steam你不需要支付订阅费，所以它没那么糟糕，但我的意思是，如果他们有一天没钱了，停止拥有它，如果他们只是关闭了你所有游戏的许可证服务器，六个月后你将无法再玩游戏了，是的，你买的所有游戏，是的，绝对，而且我仍然有游戏，我在打包时看到了我从，你知道，2000年之前，1995年，1999年，你知道，所有这些很棒的老派游戏，玩X-Com的东西，不，我没有那么久远的，好吧，但你知道，比如，呃，也许它们就像最初的StarCraft，我没有那么久远的。哦，好吧。但，你知道，比如，也许最初的StarCraft。
I don't even know what year that was. Maybe that was in the 2000s. But I have my copies of that. The Diablo 2, which that's a little bit newer. But, you know, games like that, which I still have and I can install them. If those were on some distribution service that had gone away between then and now, I wouldn't be able to get them anymore. Yeah, that's true.
我甚至不知道那是哪一年。也许是在2000年代。但我有那些游戏的副本。比如《暗黑破坏神2》，那稍微新一点。但是，你知道，像那样的游戏，我仍然保留着，而且可以安装它们。如果它们是在某个现在已经不存在的分发服务上，我就再也无法获取它们了。是的，确实如此。
It's definitely true. And, I mean, not only do you have to worry about the distribution surface going away but um you know a lot of older games you can like emulate them with dos box for example but it's like they might you know the drm might make it hard to like emulate these games and you know preserve them yeah i guess you should point out it's not the fact that you couldn't download the game anymore because you could always back that up yourself if you're worried about it but that the games now actively or some of the steam ones actively go out and ping the steam servers and make sure you're still an authentic user and this and that and if it
这绝对是真的。而且，我的意思是，你不仅要担心分发服务消失，而且嗯，你知道很多老游戏，你可以用DOSBox之类的东西来模拟它们，但问题是，你知道，DRM（数字版权管理）可能会让模拟这些游戏并保存它们变得困难。是的，我想你应该指出，这并不是说你不能再下载游戏了，因为如果你担心的话，你总是可以自己备份，而是现在的游戏，或者说Steam上的一些游戏，会主动去ping Steam服务器，确认你仍然是一个合法的用户，诸如此类，如果它
doesn't detect after a certain amount of time it'll basically lock you out yeah i was playing uh thief 3 on steam and uh i guess while i was playing my internet went out and uh at some point just kicked me out of the game it was really frustrating it's not even a multiplayer game hmm yeah that's the part that's kind of disconcerting anyway so i'm not sure that moving to that model is the best yeah good point so uh oh well yeah time for that that part of the show tools of the bi-week tool of the bi-week so why don't you go first since mine is kind of ham-fisted it's pretty heavy uh-oh oh that's that's kind of scary oh i'm i'm worried now um so mine is uh talking about notch and minecraft i've been using this tool to play now that i've
在一段时间后检测不到，它基本上就会把你锁在外面。是的，我当时在Steam上玩《神偷3》，我想在我玩的时候网络断了，然后在某个时刻它就把我踢出了游戏，这真的很令人沮丧。它甚至不是一个多人游戏。嗯，是的，这部分确实让人不安。总之，我不确定转向那种模式是最好的。是的，好观点。所以，嗯，好吧，是时候进入节目的那个环节了，双周工具，双周工具。所以为什么你不先来，因为我的那个有点笨拙，挺沉重的。噢，噢，那有点吓人。噢，我现在很担心。嗯，所以我的那个是关于Notch和《我的世界》的。我一直在使用这个工具来玩，现在我已经
moved well even before i moved i used it but to play minecraft with my family and yes we're nerd and uh the tool is hamachi and um it used to be a separate service but now it's part of log me in which is a company that offers a variety of remote login type products. And it's not open source, but it works really nice, really well. It's really easy to use. So I kind of, sticking with my sequence of not using open source tools, why Jason uses only open source tools. Hamachi allows you to run a program on your computer which creates basically a second network device like your normal Wi-Fi or your Ethernet.
搬家了，嗯，甚至在我搬家之前我就用过它，但现在是为了和我的家人一起玩《我的世界》，是的，我们是书呆子，嗯，这个工具是Hamachi，嗯，它过去是一个独立的服务，但现在它是LogMeIn的一部分，这是一家提供各种远程登录类产品的公司。它不是开源的，但它运行得非常好，非常棒。它真的很容易使用。所以我有点，坚持我不使用开源工具的序列，为什么Jason只使用开源工具。Hamachi允许你在你的电脑上运行一个程序，它基本上创建了第二个网络设备，就像你普通的Wi-Fi或以太网一样。
But the difference is this one, when you connect to it, tunnels your traffic over your other connection. And it allows, for instance, if Jason runs a version of Hamachi and I run one, and we create a virtual network, name it, have a login and password if we want. And then him and I are on the same, what appears to be local network, because Hamachi bridges those together. And so if you point a game at an IP address that is serviced by the Hamachi adapter, that's kind of a virtual adapter, then it'll talk to it, and it'll see, hey, Patrick, jason's over there you want to play with him and you know i can say yeah and we can just play um like we're on a land even though we're
但区别在于，当你连接到它时，它会通过你的其他连接对你的流量进行隧道传输。它允许，例如，如果Jason运行一个版本的Hamachi，我也运行一个，我们创建一个虚拟网络，给它命名，如果我们愿意的话，还可以设置登录名和密码。然后他和我就处于同一个看起来像是本地网络的网络中，因为Hamachi把它们桥接在了一起。所以如果你把一个游戏指向一个由Hamachi适配器服务的IP地址，那是一种虚拟适配器，那么它就会与它通信，它会看到，嘿，Patrick，Jason在那边，你想和他一起玩吗？你知道，我可以说是的，我们就可以玩了，嗯，就像我们在局域网（LAN）上一样，即使我们
very far apart yeah so let's let's talk a little bit about like we can go in a little bit more detail on hamachi just what so maybe you could explain what are the like things that hamachi solves like why couldn't you just connect to, say, your brother's computer directly? Yeah, so the idea is that, first, if you're going to go onto the internet and connect to something, you have to open up all of your ports for somebody to be able to get to you. And normally, since that's a bad thing that people can just connect to a server running on your computer and maybe do whatever they want, a lot of people's routers their isps whatever it will will block ports block traffic that's incoming so you can't really host
相隔很远。是的，所以让我们谈谈，我们可以更详细地讨论一下Hamachi，所以也许你可以解释一下Hamachi解决了什么问题，比如为什么你不能直接连接到，比如说，你兄弟的电脑？是的，所以这个想法是，首先，如果你要上网并连接到某样东西，你必须打开你所有的端口，以便别人能够连接到你。通常情况下，由于人们可以连接到你电脑上运行的服务器并可能做任何他们想做的事情是一件坏事，很多人的路由器、他们的ISP（互联网服务提供商）等等都会阻止端口，阻止传入的流量，所以你不能真正地托管
servers a lot of things that go against you being able to do that just on your local box and so if my brother tried to connect to the server running on my computer he wouldn't even be able to see it and even if i opened up all that stuff and allowed him to see it on a certain ip address my ip address might move so then i have to solve that problem so you've got this you know kind of issue after issue after issue yeah like like the way to explain it is uh you know you have you live in what's like a what's called a address space and so you could think of this address space as literally being an address like an envelope but the problem is that it's recursive so what that means is for someone to get to you they have to send an envelope to your router and that envelope your router
服务器，很多事情都阻碍了你在本地机器上这样做。所以如果我兄弟试图连接到我电脑上运行的服务器，他甚至无法看到它。即使我打开了所有那些东西，并允许他在某个IP地址上看到它，我的IP地址也可能会变动，所以我必须解决那个问题。所以你遇到了这种，你知道，一个接一个的问题。是的，就像解释它的方式是，嗯，你知道，你生活在所谓的地址空间中，所以你可以把这个地址空间想象成字面上的一个地址，就像一个信封，但问题是它是递归的。所以这意味着，为了让别人找到你，他们必须发送一个信封到你的路由器，那个信封，你的路由器
opens it it's addressed to your router so it goes through the internet to there they see it they have to open it up and then there has to be another envelope inside that one that says hey send this one to Patrick, send this one to, you know, if you're living with your parents, send this one to Patrick's dad or send this one to whoever else is in the same, on the same router.
打开它，它是寄给你的路由器的，所以它通过互联网到达那里，他们看到它，他们必须把它打开，然后里面必须有另一个信封，上面写着“嘿，把这个发给Patrick”，或者“把这个发给”，你知道，如果你和父母住在一起，“把这个发给Patrick的爸爸”，或者发给任何也在同一个路由器上的人。
So the problem is that the person from the outside doesn't know that he has to package all these envelopes inside of each other because all he sees is your router. So he'll just send you an envelope with your router's address, and the router opens it and says, what is this? I'm a router. I don't play Minecraft, and just throws it away. So what Hamachi does is that you connect to Hamachi, and then the other guy connects to Hamachi, and then Hamachi does all of this negotiation so that when Patrick's brother tries to connect to his machine, he knows to send these send these envelopes inside of each other. Yeah. And Hamachi handles the setting up of the connection. But then you connect directly to the other person. Right. So it doesn't like all your traffic doesn't have to flow through Hamachi.
所以问题是，外面的人不知道他必须把所有这些信封一个套一个地包装起来，因为他看到的只有你的路由器。所以他只会给你寄一个写着你路由器地址的信封，路由器打开它说，这是什么？我是个路由器。我不玩《我的世界》，然后就把它扔掉了。所以Hamachi所做的是，你连接到Hamachi，然后另一个人连接到Hamachi，然后Hamachi完成所有这些协商，这样当Patrick的兄弟试图连接到他的机器时，他知道要把这些信封一个套一个地发送。是的。而且Hamachi处理连接的建立。但之后你是直接连接到对方的。对。所以并不是你所有的流量都必须流经Hamachi。
It flows just directly between me and my brother. But it handles the setting up of that tunnel, as it were. And VPN does the same thing, a virtual private network. There's a lot of tools to do that. But they require a lot of configuration. And because Hamachi has a server in the cloud that handles the arrangements, so we can each connect to the server in the cloud, and then the server in the cloud connects us together,
它只是直接在我和我兄弟之间流动。但它处理了那个隧道的建立，可以这么说。VPN也做同样的事情，虚拟专用网络。有很多工具可以做到这一点。但它们需要大量的配置。而且因为Hamachi在云端有一个服务器来处理安排，所以我们可以各自连接到云端的服务器，然后云端的服务器把我们连接在一起，
versus in a normal VPN, you have to run the server somewhere that somebody can get to in order to be able to set up this other connection, which adds just, you got to have a computer on all the time, or you configure it, it just becomes kind of a mess. Yep, yeah, exactly. So this tool's pretty nice if you're trying to solve that problem.
而普通的VPN，你必须在某个人可以访问的地方运行服务器，以便能够建立这个其他连接，这增加了，你必须一直开着一台电脑，或者你配置它，它就变得有点乱。是的，是的，完全正确。所以如果你想解决这个问题，这个工具相当不错。
It has some other features too, like when a person joins, you can see who's on there, you can message them, and it's completely free if you're using it non-commercially. There may be some limit on the number of computers or that kind of thing, but they're reasonably high, so I've never run into a problem where I needed to pay for it, and I don't use it commercially, so it's exactly what I need, and it saves me spending
它还有一些其他功能，比如当一个人加入时，你可以看到谁在上面，你可以给他们发消息，而且如果你是非商业用途，它是完全免费的。电脑数量或其他类似的东西可能有一些限制，但它们相当高，所以我从来没有遇到过需要付费的问题，而且我不进行商业使用，所以它正是我所需要的，它节省了我花费
hours and hours uh trying to get it set up just so i can play my game yeah definitely hamachi's awesome um so yeah that's a that's a really nice tool that's one that we probably should have mentioned earlier it's fantastic so my tool all right now that you've said such nice things about my tool, my tool of the bi-week is low-level virtual machine, LLVM. And so this tool is pretty amazing. But let me sort of set the stage here. You know, we talked about C++. Actually, we talked about C. And we talked about Java.
数小时试图设置它，只是为了能玩我的游戏。是的，绝对，Hamachi太棒了。嗯，所以是的，那是一个非常好的工具，那是我们可能应该早点提到的，它太棒了。所以我的工具，好了，既然你对我的工具说了这么多好话，我的双周工具是低级虚拟机，LLVM。所以这个工具非常神奇。但让我先铺垫一下。你知道，我们谈到了C++。实际上，我们谈到了C。我们谈到了Java。
About C. And we talked about the difference between these two. I mean, With C, you're talking directly to the hardware, directly to the memory. If you have an array in C of length 10 and you try and access element 11,
关于C。我们谈到了这两者之间的区别。我的意思是，使用C，你是直接与硬件对话，直接与内存对话。如果你在C中有一个长度为10的数组，而你试图访问第11个元素，
now you're reading something off your operating system or you're reading a part of someone else's program. It's at such a low level. In the end, all this stuff turns into electricity. So the idea of getting an error and things like that, when it comes down to electricity, it doesn't matter.
现在你正在读取操作系统中的某些东西，或者你正在读取别人程序的一部分。它处于如此低的级别。最终，所有这些东西都变成了电。所以出现错误之类的想法，当归结为电时，这并不重要。
You're just going to get something back. And so that's sort of an oversimplification. But basically, C will let you do just about anything. Java, on the other hand will throw an exception which just just add a caveat we haven't actually talked about that yet uh as one of our episodes we haven't talked about what java yet we haven't done java no i'm almost sure we it's okay i just checked really oh we've done a language of the virtual machine though right maybe yes we've done python matlab okay let's go with python then i just didn't want people to be confused like oh no
你只会得到一些东西回来。所以这是一种过度简化。但基本上，C会让你做几乎任何事情。另一方面，Java会抛出一个异常，这只是，加一个警告，我们实际上还没有谈到那个，嗯，作为我们的一集，我们还没有谈到Java，我们还没有做Java。不，我几乎确定我们，没关系，我刚才查了一下，真的，噢，我们做过虚拟机语言，对吧？也许是的，我们做过Python，Matlab。好吧，那我们就用Python吧，我只是不想让人们感到困惑，比如“噢，不，
i missed an episode wow we'll definitely have to do java that that's exciting because i really like java um so yeah so python if you have an array um of length 10 and you're trying to access element 11 python's running in a virtual machine a fake fake machine. You think of it as like, you know, the memory's fake, the electricity's fake, everything in the machine's emulated. And so it knows that, you know, element 11, it doesn't exist, that there's only 10 elements. And if you tried to go beyond that, now you're in some no man's land. And so the virtual machine can sort of analyze itself and say, oh, this isn't going to work. And so it can throw an error, which is much, much better than just giving you some random data, right?
我错过了一集”。哇，我们一定要做Java，那太令人兴奋了，因为我真的很喜欢Java。嗯，所以是的，所以Python，如果你有一个长度为10的数组，而你试图访问第11个元素，Python是在一个虚拟机中运行的，一个假的机器。你把它想象成，你知道，内存是假的，电是假的，机器里的一切都是模拟的。所以它知道，你知道，第11个元素，它不存在，只有10个元素。如果你试图超越它，现在你就进入了无人区。所以虚拟机可以对自己进行分析并说，噢，这行不通。所以它可以抛出一个错误，这比仅仅给你一些随机数据要好得多，对吧？
You would rather have an error and be able to go in and fix it than you just get some random data and maybe you don't realize that there's a problem until it's too late so what would be but again the reason why people use c as we talked about in the c episode is that it's extremely fast really really fast so what you'd like the ideal thing is if you could compile c like in different ways so if you had the regular way where you compile the C straight to the machine code and you have this super fast program, but then another way where you could compile C to a virtual machine and check for errors. So maybe you run it on the virtual machine for a while and then once you trust it enough there, then you run it on the machine. So low-level virtual machine this is part of what LLVM does is you can compile C code actually you can compile from C,
你宁愿有一个错误并能够进去修复它，也不愿仅仅得到一些随机数据，也许直到为时已晚你才意识到有问题。所以，但同样，人们使用C的原因，正如我们在C那一集谈到的，是因为它非常快，真的非常快。所以你想要的理想情况是，如果你能以不同的方式编译C，如果你有常规的方式，你把C直接编译成机器码，你有一个超级快的程序，但还有另一种方式，你可以把C编译成虚拟机并检查错误。所以也许你在虚拟机上运行它一段时间，一旦你在那里足够信任它，然后你就在机器上运行它。所以低级虚拟机，这是LLVM的一部分，你可以编译C代码，实际上你可以从C、
Java, Python, a bunch of languages. It's basically just a definition of a virtual machine. Yeah it's sort of like a super virtual machine. So you can compile from many languages to this LLVM and you can run in this controlled environment and so you can run your app you know for like a month under this controlled environment it might run slower but you're fine with that maybe you don't have a lot of users yet or you you know spend extra money for some extra hardware in the cloud or something and then once you trust that your programs working then you can run it on the machine code so another
Java、Python，一堆语言编译。它基本上只是一个虚拟机的定义。是的，它有点像一个超级虚拟机。所以你可以从许多语言编译到这个LLVM，你可以在这个受控环境中运行，所以你可以运行你的应用程序，你知道，比如在一个月内在这个受控环境下，它可能运行得更慢，但你对此没问题，也许你还没有很多用户，或者你，你知道，在云端为一些额外的硬件多花钱，或者其他什么，一旦你信任你的程序在工作，那么你就可以在机器码上运行它。所以另一个
awesome thing about llvm is that people have written uh i guess would you call it a compiler or a decompiler but people have written programs which go from LLVM to another language. So you can actually go from LLVM to C or you can go from LLVM to Java or LLVM to JavaScript, which is what we'll be talking about later today. So, for example, let's say you have a lot of Python code and you also have like a bunch of C code. And you want them all to sort of play nice together you could combine you can compile both of them to LLVM and the LLVM will handle sort of the communication and things like that there's part of like an LLVM library you can use and then you can decompile that or I guess recompile that to C yeah I would say recompile yeah and now you have a C program.
关于LLVM的棒的事情是，人们已经编写了，嗯，我猜你会称之为编译器或反编译器，但人们已经编写了从LLVM到另一种语言的程序。所以你实际上可以从LLVM到C，或者你可以从LLVM到Java，或者LLVM到JavaScript，这就是我们今天晚些时候要谈论的。所以，例如，假设你有很多Python代码，你也有很多C代码。你想让它们都很好地协同工作，你可以把它们都编译成LLVM，LLVM将处理某种通信之类的事情，这是LLVM库的一部分，你可以使用它，然后你可以反编译它，或者我猜是重新编译它到C。是的，我会说重新编译。是的，现在你有一个C程序。
Also, JavaScript is the only language that works in the web browser, but you might not want to use JavaScript for reasons that we'll talk about later in the show. So you write your code in, say, Java or Python, compile your code to LLVM, and then go from LLVM to JavaScript. And now your Python code runs in the web browser. So there's a bunch of awesome things you can do. I just kind of scratched the surface. But definitely you should check out LLVM. The other big thing, the nice advantage that LLVM has, which maybe we'll have to talk about it in a show one time because there's a lot here,
此外，JavaScript是唯一在Web浏览器中工作的语言，但你可能不想使用JavaScript，原因我们稍后会在节目中讨论。所以你用，比如说，Java或Python编写你的代码，把你的代码编译成LLVM，然后从LLVM到JavaScript。现在你的Python代码就在Web浏览器中运行了。所以你可以做很多很棒的事情。我只是触及了表面。但你一定要看看LLVM。另一个大事情，LLVM拥有的一个很好的优势，也许我们以后得在节目中谈谈，因为这里有很多东西，
but since there's so many kind of front ends, languages that can be compiled to LLVM, and then it's a common base that once you're in LLVM, people have done a lot of research in academia and for companies. They've written a lot of optimizers for LLVM that say once something's been compiled to that, here's how we optimize it. We don't care where it came from. But once it's in this language, we'll write all these really awesome optimizers,
但因为有这么多前端，可以编译到LLVM的语言，然后它是一个共同的基础，一旦你进入了LLVM，人们在学术界和公司里做了很多研究。他们为LLVM编写了很多优化器，说一旦某样东西被编译成那样，这就是我们如何优化它。我们不在乎它来自哪里。但一旦它在这个语言中，我们就会编写所有这些非常棒的优化器，
analysis programs. We'll transform it, make it more optimal in some way, but keep the functionality. And then you can compile that to assembly, to run natively, or to another language or whatever. And you get the benefit that because it's common across all of these languages on the front end you get the same optimization as opposed to just having that for a single language yeah i mean one thing that i um sort
分析程序。我们将转换它，使它在某种程度上更优化，但保持功能。然后你可以把它编译成汇编，以原生方式运行，或者编译成另一种语言或其他什么。你得到的好处是，因为它在所有这些前端语言中是通用的，你得到了相同的优化，而不是仅仅为单一语言拥有它。是的，我的意思是，我，嗯，某种程度上
of alluded to but didn't mention completely is you can go from say c to llvm and then to machine code and that might sound worse because you have this extra step, but because of the reasons Patrick mentioned, it's been shown that it's actually the code that's generated is better. So going from C to LLVM to machine code, actually, again, your mileage may vary, but often produces better machine, faster machine code than if you went straight from C to machine code. Well, even big C compiler, C++ compiler, GCC, use an intermediate format. They just don't typically, it's not, other people don't really output it.
暗示过但没有完全提到的一点是，你可以从，比如说，C到LLVM，然后再到机器码，这听起来可能更糟，因为你多了这一步，但由于Patrick提到的原因，事实证明，生成的代码实际上更好。所以从C到LLVM再到机器码，实际上，同样，你的结果可能会有所不同，但通常会产生比你直接从C到机器码更好的机器码，更快的机器码。嗯，甚至大的C编译器，C++编译器，GCC，也使用中间格式。他们只是通常不，它不是，其他人并不真正输出它。
It just GCC outputs it. Right. So GCC outputs this intermediate language that's easier to do optimizations on. Kind of like they do a first, it's not really just one pass, but they do some passes and output this language. Then they use the optimizer on that, and then they put that out to assembly. And so this is kind of the same idea,
只是GCC输出它。对。所以GCC输出这种中间语言，更容易进行优化。有点像他们做第一次，它并不真正只是一次传递，但他们做一些传递并输出这种语言。然后他们在上面使用优化器，然后他们把它输出到汇编。所以这有点像同一个想法，
but just making it more open and encouraging more people to output that intermediate format. Right, because the guys who work on GCC, making things run fast is their whole life. I mean, if you could make your code run faster, think about all the things that are built on C. Like we've talked about how Python is written in C. The operating system. That's right.
但只是让它更开放，鼓励更多人输出那种中间格式。对，因为那些在GCC工作的人，让事情运行得快是他们的全部生活。我的意思是，如果你能让你的代码运行得更快，想想所有建立在C之上的东西。就像我们谈到的Python是如何用C编写的。操作系统。没错。
So, so many things are written in C. If you can get even a 1% improvement in C, I mean, you'd probably save millions of dollars in electricity and processing power. So, the guys who are writing GCC are really into performance. Meanwhile, the guys who are writing Python, they're more into, you know, engineer, I guess, saving time. Productivity. Right, exactly. They're more into productivity. So, they don't really spend the kind of time that the GCC guys spend on optimization. They want to make something that's flexible and that allows you to develop fast. So by creating LLVM, we're sort of combining the best of both worlds. It's like the language guys can focus on the language,
所以，很多东西都是用C编写的。如果你能获得哪怕1%的C改进，我的意思是，你可能会节省数百万美元的电费和处理能力。所以，那些编写GCC的人真的很注重性能。与此同时，那些编写Python的人，他们更注重，你知道，工程师，我猜，节省时间。生产力。对，完全正确。他们更注重生产力。所以，他们并没有真正花费GCC人员在优化上花费的那种时间。他们想制造一些灵活的东西，允许你快速开发。所以通过创建LLVM，我们正在结合两者的优点。这就像语言人员可以专注于语言，
and the compiler guys can focus on LLVM, which helps every language. Good tool. Yeah, awesome. So now let's jump into some JavaScript. JavaScript. So somebody... All right, so first question I got to ask. All right.
编译器人员可以专注于LLVM，这有助于每一种语言。好工具。是的，太棒了。所以现在让我们跳进一些JavaScript。JavaScript。所以有人……好了，所以第一个问题我得问。好了。
How does JavaScript relate to Java? Okay. So JavaScript does not in any way relate to Java. What? And this is just... I feel ripped off. I think what it is, I think people in Silicon Valley are just obsessed with coffee. But yeah, JavaScript has nothing to do with Java. So when we do the Java show, which maybe we'll do.
JavaScript和Java有什么关系？好的。所以JavaScript与Java没有任何关系。什么？这只是……我觉得被骗了。我想是这样的，我认为硅谷的人只是痴迷于咖啡。但是是的，JavaScript和Java没有任何关系。所以当我们做Java节目时，也许我们会做。
Well, we'll leave a couple of shows in between just because of the name issue. Just because we don't want people to think that there's any relation but yeah between javascript and java i thought there was for the longest time i thought there was a relation between the two yeah me too i mean i never knew what it was but i always thought there was something but yeah there is actually nothing um to do between those two so so the story goes i guess and and maybe people don't know completely for sure but um netscape was developing a language to add interactivity to their very early browser i think netscape 2 version 2 kind of time range i don't remember the the years but
嗯，我们会留出几期节目，仅仅是因为名字的问题。仅仅因为我们不想让人们认为两者之间有任何关系。但是的，在JavaScript和Java之间，我一直以为有关系。是的，我也是。我的意思是，我从来不知道那是什么，但我一直以为有什么东西。但是的，这两者之间实际上没有任何关系。所以故事是这样的，我猜，也许人们并不完全确定，但嗯，Netscape正在开发一种语言，为他们非常早期的浏览器添加交互性，我想是Netscape 2，2.0版本那个时间范围，我不记得年份了，但
they were calling it live script and LiveScript was their name. But Java was really big and had a lot of kind, or not big at the time, but was new and was gaining popularity. People were really excited about it. And Netscape went to, at that time, Sun, who was developing Java, and said, hey, we would like to be able to use the name JavaScript.
他们称之为LiveScript，LiveScript是他们的名字。但Java当时真的很火，有很多种，或者当时并不火，但它是新的，并且正在获得普及。人们真的很兴奋。Netscape去了当时正在开发Java的Sun公司，说，嘿，我们想能够使用JavaScript这个名字。
I assume that's what happened. This is the most plausible explanation I've heard. And that they wanted to name it JavaScript because they wanted to be associated with all the popularity of Java. And Sun was willing to do that because they wanted Netscape to have Java applets be able to be run in their browser.
我假设这就是发生的事情。这是我听到的最合理的解释。他们想把它命名为JavaScript，因为他们想与Java的所有流行度联系起来。Sun愿意这样做，因为他们希望Netscape能在他们的浏览器中运行Java小程序。
And so it was kind of a, what do you call that? A horse trade? Yeah. That JavaScript could become javascript which supposedly i guess sounds better and they would have the rights to name it that and then java would be able to have their um java run in the netscape browser and so i guess it was a win-win and then netscape was big on the idea of being able to be the only ones to be able to call it JavaScript so it could be theirs. And because they got an exclusive license from Sun to do that, they knew nobody else would be able to call their specific thing JavaScript.
所以这是一种，你叫它什么？马匹交易？是的。JavaScript可以成为JavaScript，这据我猜听起来更好，他们将拥有命名它的权利，然后Java将能够让他们的Java在Netscape浏览器中运行，所以我猜这是一个双赢。然后Netscape非常热衷于成为唯一能够称之为JavaScript的人，这样它就可以是他们的了。因为他们从Sun那里获得了独家许可来做这件事，他们知道没有其他人能够称他们的特定东西为JavaScript。
Oh, what a mess. I guess. That's what I've heard. But then it kind of got weird because then Netscape wanted to, I guess it was still them at this point, they wanted to get it standardized. And so they took it, tried to find somebody who would standardize, you know, ISO, who are the other people, the various committees. Oh, W3C, right? Or WC3.
噢，真是一团糟。我猜。这就是我听到的。但后来它变得有点奇怪，因为Netscape想，我猜当时还是他们，他们想把它标准化。所以他们拿着它，试图找到一个会标准化的人，你知道，ISO，还有其他人，各种委员会。噢，W3C，对吧？或者WC3。
Yeah, that's another one. These kind of people to, you know, standard, I give them a standard for JavaScript, and they couldn't get anybody to do it. So the European, the ECMA, decided they would do it, and so they produced their standardized version of JavaScript. But they couldn't call it JavaScript because that was only Netscape-specific, and so they called that ECMA script.
是的，那是另一个。这些人，你知道，标准，我给他们一个JavaScript的标准，他们找不到任何人来做。所以欧洲的ECMA决定他们会做，所以他们制作了他们的标准化版本的JavaScript。但他们不能称之为JavaScript，因为那是Netscape特有的，所以他们称之为ECMAScript。
So we don't really have live script around anymore but you do hear the names javascript and ecma script and they kind of do mean the same thing but in reality we probably should have named the the show ecma script because it's what you know is the thing that everybody runs but everybody just calls it javascript yeah it's hard once you know you have so much inertia buying a name, it's hard to change it. Yes. Yeah, so yeah, JavaScript has a pretty muddy history. Yes. But it has several really important uses. It does. Okay, before we move on real quick, most of that came from a lecture I was watching that's pretty interesting because of the the history and also teaches javascript um by a guy named douglas crockford oh nice who i assume works at yahoo um but i we put we'll put the link in the show notes but it's uh crockford on javascript and he it's like very like each
所以我们现在并没有真正拥有LiveScript了，但你确实听到了JavaScript和ECMAScript这两个名字，它们确实意味着同样的事情，但实际上我们可能应该把这个节目命名为ECMAScript，因为它是你知道的每个人都在运行的东西，但每个人都只是称它为JavaScript。是的，一旦你知道你对一个名字有这么大的惯性，就很难改变它。是的。是的，所以是的，JavaScript有一段非常浑浊的历史。是的。但它有几个非常重要的用途。它确实有。好的，在我们继续之前，快速说一下，大部分内容来自我正在看的一个讲座，这很有趣，因为历史，也教JavaScript，由一个叫Douglas Crockford的人，噢，不错，我假设他在雅虎工作，但我，我们把链接放在节目说明中，但它是Crockford谈JavaScript，他，这就像非常，每一
episode's like an hour hour and a half and i think there's like four or five of them wow that's pretty cool it's definitely a lot of material and he goes over all the history and talks a lot about what javascript is so for a much more in-depth uh description you can go there but sorry yes So it's definitely a lot of material. And he goes over all the history and talks a lot about what JavaScript is. So for a much more in-depth description, you can go there. But sorry, yes, the uses of JavaScript. Did you watch any of these? These look pretty awesome. I watched the first one and kind of skipped around
集就像一个小时，一个半小时，我想有四五集。哇，那太酷了。这绝对有很多材料，他讲了所有的历史，谈了很多关于JavaScript是什么。所以对于更深入的描述，你可以去那里，但抱歉，是的。所以这绝对有很多材料。他讲了所有的历史，谈了很多关于JavaScript是什么。所以对于更深入的描述，你可以去那里。但抱歉，是的，JavaScript的用途。你看过这些吗？这些看起来很棒。我看了第一集，跳着看了一些
because I knew a lot of what he was saying and then started watching the second one. It's just long format. Somebody told me that JavaScript was based on Scheme, like way back. It's a descendant of Scheme. Is that true or is that made up? He did talk about that in there, that it was influenced by some of the... Well, we'll talk about it.
因为我知道他说的很多东西，然后开始看第二集。这只是长格式。有人告诉我JavaScript是基于Scheme的，很久以前。它是Scheme的后代。那是真的还是编造的？他确实在里面谈到了这一点，它受到了一些……嗯，我们会谈到的。
But JavaScript does have a lot of functional programming language to it. And so, yeah, it was influenced in some ways by that, yes. Cool, awesome. So, yeah, what are some of the uses of JavaScript? Why is it so popular? Well, we already talked a little bit about the, you know, kind of main one. It's kind of the language for web browsers. Yep.
但JavaScript确实有很多函数式编程语言的成分。所以，是的，它在某些方面受到了它的影响，是的。酷，太棒了。所以，是的，JavaScript有哪些用途？为什么它这么受欢迎？嗯，我们已经谈到了一点，你知道，那种主要的。它有点像Web浏览器的语言。对。
Client-side. Sorry, go ahead. I was going to say client-side web browsers. Yeah. Yeah, so it's the thing that people put in their web browser to, I guess, add interactivity? Yep. Yeah, definitely. So as we talked about in the HTML episode, the HTML code, we'll say, is called the DOM, the Document Object Model. And so this is if you write raw HTML, this is your, you know, you type the body tag and
客户端。抱歉，你继续。我本来想说客户端Web浏览器。是的。是的，所以它是人们放入Web浏览器中，我猜，添加交互性的东西？对。是的，绝对。正如我们在HTML那一集谈到的，HTML代码，我们说，被称为DOM，文档对象模型。所以这是如果你编写原始HTML，这是你的，你知道，你输入body标签和
then the, you know, the P tag for a paragraph and all that stuff. So it's really just a sheet of XML. And that sheet of XML can be thought of as this tree. So the body is actually the HTML tag is the root of the tree. And you have, you know, head and body as the two children. And, of course, head has, like, scripts, can have script tags. So you can think of this as, like, flowing down like a tree. And so you might want to do programmatic things.
然后，你知道，段落的P标签和所有那些东西。所以它真的只是一个XML表。那个XML表可以被认为是一棵树。所以body实际上是HTML标签是树的根。你有，你知道，head和body作为两个子节点。当然，head有，比如，脚本，可以有脚本标签。所以你可以把它想象成，像树一样向下流动。所以你可能想做程序化的事情。
Like, you want to scan through this tree. You know, again, you know, HTML is often generated by another language so you might want to scan through this tree and count up how many how many tags you have inside of a particular table you might want to do some sort of logic or some sort of programming on the Dom on the on the HTML that's been rendered and so JavaScript is one way to do that so So for example, you might have a block of HTML that contains records, and you might want to have a little pull-down menu that filters the records. Give me all the records that start with J.
比如，你想扫描这棵树。你知道，同样，你知道，HTML通常是由另一种语言生成的，所以你可能想扫描这棵树，计算你在特定表格中有多少个标签，你可能想对DOM，对已经渲染的HTML做某种逻辑或某种编程，所以JavaScript是做到这一点的一种方式。所以，例如，你可能有一块包含记录的HTML，你可能想有一个小的下拉菜单来过滤记录。给我所有以J开头的记录。
Now give me all the records that start with K. So you don't want to have the server generate a new page each time because the client has all those records there. You just want to alter the DOM. You just want to make some of those records invisible. So that's something that you could do in JavaScript. So JavaScript can loop through all the elements in this tree and set some of the parameters on them. Set one to visible, set one to invisible, to hidden, etc. Also, a lot of HTML5, even though it's called HTML5,
现在给我所有以K开头的记录。所以你不想让服务器每次都生成一个新页面，因为客户端有所有那些记录在那里。你只是想改变DOM。你只是想让其中一些记录不可见。所以这是你可以用JavaScript做的事情。所以JavaScript可以循环遍历这棵树中的所有元素并设置它们的一些参数。设置一个为可见，设置一个为不可见，为隐藏，等等。此外，很多HTML5，尽管它被称为HTML5，
the vast majority of it is JavaScript. So, for example, one of the things HTML5 adds is typed arrays. So if you want an array of data, as we talked about in the C episode, in JavaScript you can't really do that. You can have sort of an array of objects, in the C episode. In JavaScript, you can't really do that. You can have sort of an array of objects, but it's not really like a chunk of memory like it is in C. But now with HTML5 and typed arrays,
绝大多数是JavaScript。所以，例如，HTML5添加的事情之一是类型化数组。所以如果你想要一个数据数组，正如我们在C那一集谈到的，在JavaScript中你不能真正做到这一点。你可以有某种对象数组，在C那一集中。在JavaScript中，你不能真正做到这一点。你可以有某种对象数组，但它不像C中那样是一块内存。但现在有了HTML5和类型化数组，
you can actually ask for a block of memory, and that's important for many different tasks. Yeah, that's kind of interesting because that's kind of a divergence. JavaScript's thing has been that there's just one kind of number. Right. There's just one kind of interesting because that's kind of a divergence. JavaScript's thing has been that, you know, there's just one kind of number. Right. There's just one kind of, you know, it was just very, you know, straightforward. Just every number is a double. Yep.
你实际上可以要求一块内存，这对许多不同的任务很重要。是的，这有点有趣，因为这是一种分歧。JavaScript的事情一直是只有一种数字。对。只有一种有趣，因为这是一种分歧。JavaScript的事情一直是，你知道，只有一种数字。对。只有一种，你知道，它非常，你知道，直截了当。每个数字都是一个双精度浮点数。对。
Double floating point precision. Oh, no, actually, so in Python, every number is a double. But in JavaScript, every number is a float. I believe, yeah. But, yeah, you're right. I mean, in JavaScript, there's basically, there's float, there's object, there's array. This is pre-HTML5. And there's a couple others. I think there's like none or null. I think it's called nothing. And so that's about it. I mean, everything's either an object, which is a hash table about it i mean everything's either you know an object which is
双精度浮点精度。噢，不，实际上，在Python中，每个数字都是一个双精度浮点数。但在JavaScript中，每个数字都是一个浮点数。我相信，是的。但是，是的，你是对的。我的意思是，在JavaScript中，基本上，有浮点数，有对象，有数组。这是HTML5之前。还有几个其他的。我想有像none或null。我想它叫nothing。所以就是这样。我的意思是，一切要么是一个对象，这是一个哈希表，我的意思是，一切要么是，你知道，一个对象，这是一个
a hash table in javascript so everything's either a hash table an array a floating point number or nothing so you know it's very it's very simple in that respect yeah and i guess that's a strength but also it can be limiting right i mean if you need to do some number crunching or something like that, you need just like a block of memory. You know, the compiler, you know, at the lower level, the compiler and the machine, what they're looking for is for you to, you know, again, we're talking about electricity and, you know, memory at a really low level. You want to just access things in order. And so what JavaScript will do is, if it has an array but it isn't typed, it doesn't know that each element is going to be a number.
JavaScript中的哈希表，所以一切要么是一个哈希表，一个数组，一个浮点数，或者nothing，所以你知道，在这方面它非常简单。是的，我猜这是一个优势，但它也可能是有限制的，对吧？我的意思是，如果你需要做一些数字运算或其他什么，你需要就像一块内存。你知道，编译器，你知道，在较低的级别，编译器和机器，他们寻找的是让你，你知道，同样，我们在谈论电，你知道，在非常低的级别上的内存。你只想按顺序访问东西。所以JavaScript会做的是，如果它有一个数组但它不是类型化的，它不知道每个元素都将是一个数字。
Maybe the first element of the array is an object, the second element is a hash table, and the third element is a number. So JavaScript can't just take one chunk of memory and say, here's your array, because it doesn't really know what to expect. But HTML5 sort of adds a lot of that because performance for JavaScript has become more important. And it's been previously the fact that we talked about that on the, and we referenced it a little bit earlier
也许数组的第一个元素是一个对象，第二个元素是一个哈希表，第三个元素是一个数字。所以JavaScript不能只拿一块内存说，这是你的数组，因为它真的不知道会期待什么。但HTML5某种程度上添加了很多，因为JavaScript的性能变得更重要了。而且之前的事实是我们谈到了那个，在，我们稍微早一点提到了它
when we were talking about Hamachi, but on the client side, so the client being the person running the web browser, sitting at their home wherever they're the client and then they're connecting to a server to get the html the html5 the javascript all those things get transferred over to the client and then the client has to render and their browser has to draw the what you know ultimately ends up being the image the thing you interact with that's the web page and that's what the client side does and the javascript is the language that is the program that continues to run even once the page is loaded and the html kind of
当我们谈论Hamachi时，但在客户端，所以客户端是运行Web浏览器的人，坐在他们家里，无论他们在哪里，他们是客户端，然后他们连接到服务器以获取HTML，HTML5，JavaScript，所有这些东西都被传输到客户端，然后客户端必须渲染，他们的浏览器必须绘制，你知道，最终成为图像的东西，你与之交互的东西，那是网页，这就是客户端所做的，而JavaScript是语言，是即使在页面加载后也继续运行的程序，而HTML某种程度上
is what gets loaded describes how to load it and then the javascript goes in and says you know here's how to continue running and that's on the client side but on the server the part that's you know either the static html you know just stays as like a text file that's html they get served up or that we talked about programs generate javascript that generate html so those are often other languages like PHP or Ruby on Rails or one of the Python web frameworks or it could be even C or C++. And those run on the server and serve up the HTML and JavaScript and change parts of the JavaScript, parts of the HTML to do something based on, for instance, the time of day or what the newest news story is or what user you've logged in as. Yeah, I mean, you know, a very simple example is if you look at Gmail, you can get new emails
是加载的东西，描述了如何加载它，然后JavaScript进去说，你知道，这是如何继续运行的，那是在客户端，但在服务器上，那部分是，你知道，要么是静态HTML，你知道，只是作为文本文件保留，那是HTML，它们被服务，或者我们谈到的程序生成JavaScript，生成HTML，所以那些通常是其他语言，比如PHP或Ruby on Rails，或者Python Web框架之一，或者它甚至可以是C或C++。那些在服务器上运行，并提供HTML和JavaScript，并更改JavaScript的部分，HTML的部分，以做某事，基于，例如，一天中的时间，或者最新的新闻故事是什么，或者你以哪个用户登录。是的，我的意思是，你知道，一个非常简单的例子是，如果你看Gmail，你可以得到新的电子邮件
on Gmail without the whole page refreshing. And so we'll talk about this a little more later on, but that's JavaScript stepping in and, you know, asking Google, hey, are there any new emails? Are there any new emails? Are there any new emails? And so JavaScript gives you the ability to sort of continue processing even after you've loaded the page.
在Gmail上，而不需要整个页面刷新。所以我们稍后会多谈谈这个，但那是JavaScript介入，你知道，问Google，嘿，有新邮件吗？有新邮件吗？有新邮件吗？所以JavaScript给了你某种在页面加载后继续处理的能力。
But I wouldn't guess that on Google's side that that's JavaScript running on their server because almost always that's something else running on that end. Right. But then there's this new tool that's gained else running on that end right but then there's this new tool that's gained a lot of popularity actually it's it's kind of interesting called node.js and node.js is it's takes google's chrome's javascript engine so to get web pages to run really fast which chrome has tried to make one of their selling points well selling points there is i guess they give it away but one of the reasons to download chrome google always says is because it's really fast and as part of that they have
但我不会猜在Google那边，那是JavaScript在他们的服务器上运行，因为几乎总是那是另一端运行的其他东西。对。但后来有一个新的工具获得了另一端运行的东西，对，但后来有一个新的工具获得了很大的普及，实际上它，它有点有趣，叫node.js，node.js是，它采用Google的Chrome的JavaScript引擎，所以为了让网页运行得非常快，Chrome已经试图使其成为他们的卖点之一，嗯，卖点，我猜他们免费提供它，但下载Chrome的原因之一，Google总是说，是因为它非常快，作为其中的一部分，他们有
to figure out the way to make the interpreter that runs the javascript engine really really fast yeah i mean i remember when uh you know when gmail first came out um it took like on the order of minutes for it to load and it actually loaded this like weird javascript blob thing that then like expanded or something and then you know after it loaded the first time then it was fast but i mean it took literally over a minute to load gmail for the first time on a machine and now when you go to gmail even for the first time it's instant yeah and a lot of that's because of the effort that they've put in and others and then also kind of they've encouraged others and challenged others to put in more work to making this javascript engine really really fast right so they open sourced that engine they they called it, I think, V8.
弄清楚让运行JavaScript引擎的解释器变得非常非常快的方法。是的，我的意思是，我记得当，嗯，你知道，当Gmail刚出来时，嗯，它加载需要几分钟的时间，它实际上加载了这个像奇怪的JavaScript blob东西，然后像展开或其他什么，然后你知道，在它第一次加载后，它就快了，但我的意思是，在机器上第一次加载Gmail确实需要超过一分钟，而现在当你去Gmail时，即使是第一次，它也是瞬间的。是的，这很大程度上是因为他们投入的努力，以及其他人，然后也某种程度上，他们鼓励其他人并挑战其他人投入更多工作，使这个JavaScript引擎变得非常非常快。对，所以他们开源了那个引擎，他们称之为，我想，V8。
Yeah, that's right. Reference to an engine, I assume, a fast engine, V8. And they open sourced it. So this person took that engine, runs it on the server, and then adds in hooks so that from JavaScript, you can create the server side that serves up web pages and handles people visiting a web page, people logging in, people doing actions, and in JavaScript on the server side.
是的，那是对的。对引擎的引用，我假设，一个快速的引擎，V8。他们开源了它。所以这个人采用了那个引擎，在服务器上运行它，然后添加钩子，这样从JavaScript，你可以创建服务网页的服务器端，并处理人们访问网页，人们登录，人们做动作，以及在服务器端的JavaScript中。
And that's something that's pretty new. It was kind of very interesting, and it's catching on. Because it unifies the client- side scripting that people are writing programs to run in the browser in javascript and now they can also write code on the server that runs in javascript and it does it does all this asynchronously um and so instead of waiting for stuff it does you know you register an event to happen and then you get a callback. And it is a new and novel way of doing it, but it allows for a lot of parallelism, allows you to run more clients from a given server
这确实是相当新的东西。它非常有趣，而且正在流行起来。因为它统一了客户端脚本，人们以前用 JavaScript 在浏览器中编写程序，现在他们也可以在服务器端用 JavaScript 编写代码，而且这一切都是异步完成的。所以，你不需要等待任务完成，而是注册一个事件，然后等待回调。这是一种新颖的方法，但它允许大量的并行处理，让你能在同一台服务器上运行更多的客户端。
so you don't have to have another server to handle all the traffic. And it's catching on. It's pretty cool. I don't know that it's the first time that JavaScript's been used on the server side, but it's definitely become probably the most popular way to run JavaScript on the server side. Yeah, for sure. That's pretty awesome. So what are some of the features of JavaScript?
这样你就不需要额外的服务器来处理所有的流量了。它正在流行，非常酷。我不确定这是不是 JavaScript 第一次被用于服务器端，但它绝对已经成为目前运行 JavaScript 最流行的方式。是的，确实如此。这太棒了。那么 JavaScript 有哪些特性呢？
What are some of the things that differentiate as a language? Yeah, so JavaScript is, you know, compared to the languages that we have talked about, it's more like Python and less like C. So it's dynamically typed, similar to Python. It's got lambda functions, which means you can, you know, a function is basically an object, and you can create functions whenever you want versus.
作为一种语言，它有哪些与众不同的地方？是的，JavaScript 与我们讨论过的其他语言相比，它更像 Python 而不像 C。它是动态类型的，类似于 Python。它有 lambda 函数，这意味着函数基本上是一个对象，你可以随时创建函数，而不是……
And you don't have to give them names. That's right. So you can pass in, and the functions are first-class citizens, which we've never talked about. But, yeah, basically means a function can be an object. So you can pass functions as the argument to another function. Right. Like imagine if, I'm trying to think of a good example here.
而且你不需要给它们命名。没错。所以你可以传递函数，函数是一等公民，我们以前从未讨论过这个概念。但基本上这意味着函数可以是一个对象。所以你可以把函数作为参数传递给另一个函数。对。比如，我想举个好例子。
But oh, so a callback is a good example. Yeah, yeah. So you want to have a callback. Say, hey, I want you to go get, read bytes from a network. And instead of waiting here, I want you to call get read bytes from a network and instead of waiting here I want you to call this other function when you're done right and the other function is just going to you know do something gonna blink up make a blinking thing on your web browser let's say so a lambda function says instead of calling back this named function I'm gonna just give you the
哦，回调就是一个很好的例子。是的。你想用回调。比如，嘿，我想要你去读取网络字节。与其在这里等待，我想要你调用这个读取网络字节的函数，并在完成后调用另一个函数。而另一个函数只是做点什么，比如在你的网页浏览器上闪烁一下。所以 lambda 函数的意思是，与其回调一个具名函数，我直接给你……
code not give it a name just here's the code just run this code when you finish yep and that's an anonymous function that you pass to it yeah exactly it doesn't have a name yeah so um yes the javascript has a lambda function which is super useful um and it but one thing you know so javascript, as you mentioned, there's a V8, which is an interpreter for JavaScript. Internet Explorer has their own interpreter. Firefox has their own. I think it's called SpiderMonkey. So each browser has built in their own interpreter, their own JavaScript interpreter.
代码，不给它命名，只是说：这是代码，当你完成时运行它。没错，这就是你传递给它的匿名函数。是的，完全正确，它没有名字。所以，是的，JavaScript 有 lambda 函数，这非常有用。但有一点，正如你提到的，JavaScript 有 V8，它是 JavaScript 的解释器。Internet Explorer 有自己的解释器，Firefox 也有自己的，我想叫 SpiderMonkey。所以每个浏览器都内置了自己的 JavaScript 解释器。
And each one has its own sort of nuance. Some have different instructions. I know, for example, if you want to find out, you click the mouse, and you're writing some JavaScript program that just needs to know where you clicked on the screen. Well, in Chrome and in Firefox, you would call this function or this parameter called event.which. Actually, sorry, event.
而且每个解释器都有自己的细微差别。有些有不同的指令。我知道，例如，如果你想知道鼠标点击的位置，并且你正在编写一个需要知道屏幕点击位置的 JavaScript 程序。在 Chrome 和 Firefox 中，你会调用这个函数或参数，叫 event.which。抱歉，是 event。
Yeah, event.which tells you which keystroke or mouse button. So if you clicked the left mouse button, event.which would return zero. If you click the right mouse button, it would return one, et cetera. In IE, it's not event.which. It's something else. I don't even remember. So you have to write all these if IE, then do event.whatever it is, target or something. Otherwise, event.which, right? And so the language is full of these nuances because there's so many different interpreters.
是的，event.which 会告诉你按下了哪个键或鼠标按钮。如果你点击左键，event.which 会返回 0。如果你点击右键，它会返回 1，等等。在 IE 中，它不是 event.which，是别的东西。我甚至不记得了。所以你必须写所有这些“如果是 IE，就用 event.whatever，比如 target 之类的，否则就用 event.which”。所以这种语言充满了这些细微差别，因为有太多的解释器。
You remember, like, Python only has the CPython. Well, it has a couple others, but CPython completely dominates, right? You know, but in this case, you have many browsers, and each has a large market share. You know, I think Internet Explorer has, like, 50% of the users are on that, and the other 50% are spread across Chrome, Firefox, et cetera. Well, it's almost like the analogy is that it's different hardware platforms. Yeah, that is a good analogy.
你记得 Python 只有 CPython 吗？好吧，还有其他几个，但 CPython 完全占据主导地位。但在这种情况下，你有许多浏览器，每个都有很大的市场份额。我认为 Internet Explorer 拥有大约 50% 的用户，另外 50% 分布在 Chrome、Firefox 等浏览器中。这就像是不同的硬件平台。是的，这是一个很好的类比。
So if you had to run on like an Intel processor, and in this case, AMD happens to comply with the same standard as Intel. But IBM used to make, I guess they still make Power PCs, all free scale now, Power PC chips. Sony has the Cell processor. You know, these are all very different processors. And you need to be able to run on all of them because everybody on the Internet has essentially a different machine, a different operating system that they're using. Yep.
如果你必须在 Intel 处理器上运行，在这种情况下，AMD 恰好符合与 Intel 相同的标准。但 IBM 过去制造，我想他们现在还在制造 Power PC，现在全归飞思卡尔了，Power PC 芯片。索尼有 Cell 处理器。这些都是非常不同的处理器。你需要能够在所有这些处理器上运行，因为互联网上的每个人本质上都有不同的机器，使用不同的操作系统。没错。
And so there are several libraries, JavaScript libraries, that are designed to sort of save you the trouble of having to do all these if IE this, if Mozilla that, if Firefox that. So the most popular one is jQuery there's another one called MooTools there's no one called prototype I've used a jQuery a lot I've had a really good success with it I can't really say much about the other two but I've heard they're they're both very good as well but what they basically do is save you from having to care about what each browser does one thing to note and we'll talk about this more in the
所以有几个 JavaScript 库旨在让你免于处理“如果是 IE 就这样，如果是 Mozilla 就那样，如果是 Firefox 就那样”的麻烦。最流行的是 jQuery，还有另一个叫 MooTools，还有一个叫 Prototype。我用过很多 jQuery，效果非常好。我不能对另外两个说太多，但我听说它们也都很好。但它们基本上所做的就是让你不必关心每个浏览器怎么做。有一点需要注意，我们会在……
weaknesses section but these tools are good but they're not great I mean you know you'll still have issues your code still will run a little bit differently in IE and so you definitely need to have an environment where you can test all the different browsers. Well, we should say the tools are great. The problem is just really hard. Oh yeah, maybe that's the best way of saying it, yeah. Because, I mean, these tools are trying really hard. There's a lot of work that goes into them. They give you a lot of help. They make your life a whole lot easier. They take an impossible task and just make it hard. Yeah,
弱点部分讨论这个问题，但这些工具很好，但并不完美。我的意思是，你仍然会遇到问题，你的代码在 IE 中运行仍然会略有不同，所以你绝对需要一个可以测试所有不同浏览器的环境。好吧，我们应该说这些工具很棒。问题只是这真的很难。哦，是的，也许这是最好的说法。因为这些工具确实非常努力。它们投入了大量的工作。它们给了你很多帮助。它们让你的生活轻松多了。它们把一项不可能的任务变得困难了。是的，
and you know, another thing is that it changes constantly. Like from IE8 to IE9, they'll change a bunch of different function names and they won't be backwards compatible. And so, you know, these tools have to stay up to date, but then they also still have to backdate so that someone using IE6 or someone using IE9 or someone using Firefox, they can all see the same, get the same experience. And so that is, you know, a really, really hard problem. Yeah, definitely. So, you know, writing JavaScript, you know, can be painful. We'll talk about that a little more in the weaknesses too. But many people have written compilers which compile to JavaScript.
而且你知道，另一件事是它一直在变化。比如从 IE8 到 IE9，它们会改变很多不同的函数名，而且它们不是向后兼容的。所以这些工具必须保持更新，但它们也必须向后兼容，这样使用 IE6、IE9 或 Firefox 的人都能获得相同的体验。所以这是一个非常非常困难的问题。是的，绝对是。所以编写 JavaScript 可能会很痛苦。我们会在弱点部分多谈谈这一点。但许多人编写了编译成 JavaScript 的编译器。
So you can write languages that are, I guess, a little bit more formal and then run this compiler and generate the JavaScript. So do you have a couple in mind? Yeah. I mean, one of the big ones that, you know, kind of, I guess, is one people think about is the Google Web Toolkit, which breaks what we said before that Java and JavaScript have nothing to do with each other. Yeah, I guess. Because this actually allows you to write kind of a certain style of a Java program and then compile that to JavaScript. And Google has actually open sourced that. Yeah, open sourced it and released that so
所以你可以编写一些稍微正式一点的语言，然后运行这个编译器并生成 JavaScript。你有几个想到的吗？是的。其中一个大的，人们会想到的，是 Google Web Toolkit，它打破了我们之前说的 Java 和 JavaScript 毫无关系的说法。是的，我想是这样。因为它实际上允许你编写某种风格的 Java 程序，然后将其编译为 JavaScript。Google 实际上已经开源了它。是的，开源并发布了它，以便……
that others can use it. And you can write, they show you how to write it in Java. And then you run their program and out comes JavaScript that you can put on your page. And that allows you to build up bigger applications more quickly and not have to worry about the tediousness of writing all the JavaScript. And it also, built in, tries to handle about kind of the tediousness of writing all the JavaScript. And it also built in tries to handle a lot of the stuff like jQuery and others will do
其他人可以使用它。他们向你展示如何用 Java 编写代码。然后你运行他们的程序，输出就是你可以放在页面上的 JavaScript。这允许你更快地构建更大的应用程序，而不必担心编写所有 JavaScript 的繁琐。而且它还内置了尝试处理……编写所有 JavaScript 的繁琐。它还内置了尝试处理很多像 jQuery 和其他工具会做的事情……
as far as cross-browser problems. Yeah, I mean, you know, jQuery is sort of limited in the sense that, you know, you're writing JavaScript and you're calling their functions and they're trying to do whatever they can to sort of deal with these browser issues. But, you know, ideally what you'd love is to write something else and have it create separate, just completely separate JavaScript files. And just have something on top that says, if you're IE, run this JavaScript file, otherwise run that one.
关于跨浏览器的问题。是的，我的意思是，jQuery 在某种意义上是有限的，因为你是在编写 JavaScript 并调用它们的函数，它们正试图尽其所能处理这些浏览器问题。但是，理想情况下，你希望编写其他东西并让它创建单独的、完全独立的 JavaScript 文件。并在顶部放一些东西，说“如果你是 IE，运行这个 JavaScript 文件，否则运行那个”。
And do it at that level where you really have the most control. Mm-hm. Yeah. So- What about, we talked about LLVM before. I have a feeling we're about to get another talk about that. Another one, compiler JavaScript is mscripten. What that does is it takes C++ code, compiles it to LLVM, and then compiles that to JavaScript.
并在你真正拥有最大控制权的层面上完成它。嗯。是的。那么——我们之前谈到了 LLVM。我有种感觉我们又要谈论这个了。另一个编译 JavaScript 的是 Emscripten。它所做的是获取 C++ 代码，将其编译为 LLVM，然后将其编译为 JavaScript。
This is pretty freaking wild. Imagine all the things that have JavaScript. That's crazy. And so this is pretty freaking wild, right? Because, I mean, imagine all the things that have been written in C++. Like, let me just give an example. Imagine if you worked at Microsoft. You could compile Microsoft Office to JavaScript. Like the entire thing. Oh, not quite. Yeah, no, actually, LLVM has support for translating different things.
这真是太疯狂了。想象一下所有拥有 JavaScript 的东西。这太疯狂了。所以这真是太疯狂了，对吧？因为想象一下所有用 C++ 编写的东西。让我举个例子。想象一下你在微软工作。你可以把 Microsoft Office 编译成 JavaScript。就像整个东西。哦，不完全是。是的，不，实际上，LLVM 支持翻译不同的东西。
So, in other words, the, what's the drawing thing? The Windows drawing library. Paint? No, no, no, I mean the C routines. GDX, I think. Is that what it's called? Oh, okay. So, anyways, the library, which, you know, actually handles, like, drawing the widgets on the screen and drawing the windows and the framework and all that stuff.
所以，换句话说，那个……绘图的东西是什么？Windows 绘图库。Paint？不，不，我是指 C 例程。GDX，我想是这个名字。是叫这个吗？哦，好吧。所以，无论如何，这个库实际上处理了在屏幕上绘制小部件、绘制窗口、框架等等。
MFC, that's what I was thinking of. So they have different libraries. I don't know if they have MFC, but where they've sort of told LLVM sort of how to translate that to JavaScript. And so I wouldn't be surprised if you could actually do this. I wouldn't be surprised if you had to put in a fair amount of work and didn't just compile it. Wow, look, it works.
MFC，我刚才想的就是这个。所以他们有不同的库。我不知道他们是否有 MFC，但他们以某种方式告诉 LLVM 如何将其翻译成 JavaScript。所以我不会惊讶如果你真的能做到这一点。我不会惊讶如果你必须投入相当多的工作，而不是仅仅编译它。哇，看，它成功了。
I've been able to compile some things. One thing that somebody compiled was there's a library called Bullet, which is a physics engine. And it came with OpenGL samples where you can move boxes around and throw boxes in this 3D environment. And he just ran it through this Emscripten. And it knows to turn the OpenGL calls into WebGL calls. And he had the Bullet physics engine running in browser. That's pretty cool. It's pretty wild.
我已经能够编译一些东西了。有人编译的一件事是一个叫 Bullet 的库，它是一个物理引擎。它附带了 OpenGL 示例，你可以在这个 3D 环境中移动盒子并投掷盒子。他只是通过这个 Emscripten 运行它。它知道如何将 OpenGL 调用转换为 WebGL 调用。他让 Bullet 物理引擎在浏览器中运行了。这太酷了。这太疯狂了。
You should definitely check out some of the demos. Yeah, I'll have to check that out. So since this is LLVM in the middle, does that mean that you can, in theory, use other languages as well? So like Java or Python or anything that can compile to LLVM? Yeah. As a front end? I mean, the Inscripten engine takes an LLVM file as a parameter. And I don't think it cares where that file came from so yeah you could definitely yeah i don't think anything that compiles the llvm now can run
你绝对应该看看其中的一些演示。是的，我得去看看。既然中间是 LLVM，那是不是意味着理论上你也可以使用其他语言？比如 Java 或 Python 或任何可以编译成 LLVM 的语言？是的。作为前端？我的意思是，Emscripten 引擎将 LLVM 文件作为参数。我不认为它关心该文件来自哪里，所以是的，你绝对可以。我不认为任何现在编译成 LLVM 的东西都可以在浏览器中原生运行……
natively in a browser which is pretty wild what if i want to write javascript right before going to bed i might i might be in my pajamas oh man yeah so so somebody had an awesome idea they said what if we basically took the google web toolkit and ported the entire thing to python and that's what they did and so pajamas is a python to javascript compiler and so they try and keep it relatively up to date with the latest google web toolkit it is spelled pyjamas yeah yeah with a y that's right pretty awesome so you can code pyjamas in your pajamas maybe we need to do that this needs to be a milestone i'm pretty sure you'd get an achievement for that oh that might be good uh Another one is reiterating your assertion that people in Silicon Valley are addicted to their coffee, is CoffeeScript. So it's a play on Java, which is,
这太疯狂了。如果我想在睡觉前写 JavaScript 怎么办？我可能穿着睡衣。哦，天哪。是的，所以有人有一个很棒的想法，他们说如果我们基本上采用 Google Web Toolkit 并将整个东西移植到 Python 会怎样？这就是他们所做的，所以 Pyjamas 是一个 Python 到 JavaScript 的编译器。他们试图让它与最新的 Google Web Toolkit 保持相对同步。它是拼写为 Pyjamas，是的，带一个 y，没错。太棒了，所以你可以在睡衣里写 Pyjamas。也许我们需要这样做，这必须是一个里程碑，我敢肯定你会因此获得成就。哦，那可能不错。另一个是重申你的断言，即硅谷的人们对咖啡上瘾，那就是 CoffeeScript。所以它是对 Java 的一种戏仿，也就是……
you know, coffee to CoffeeScript. And so this is kind of an extension, a growth of JavaScript. It adds some of the features that are trying to come into Java, and it kind of makes even more brief syntax and some, I guess, what's called syntactic sugar. So things, different ways, different notation that you can use that allows you to be more shorthand and doing more powerful things with the language and it compiles it's another language that compiles to javascript
你知道，咖啡到 CoffeeScript。所以这是一种扩展，JavaScript 的增长。它添加了一些试图进入 Java 的特性，并且它使语法更加简洁，以及一些所谓的“语法糖”。所以，不同的方式，不同的符号，你可以使用，允许你更简短地做更强大的事情，它编译……它是另一种编译成 JavaScript 的语言。
but it looks a lot like javascript so some of these other things it would be very hard to write kind of one part in hand-coded javascript and one part in a c++ to llvm to javascript you know that's kind of could get messy. Versus like the CoffeeScript, it's very easy to sit side by side with handcrafted JavaScript. Yeah, definitely. And so the last one we have is called Clojure Tools. Not to be confused with Clojure, which is a JavaScript extension. Clojure Tools with an S is, well, CLOS, closure tools, is it's a language that's very similar to JavaScript, but it adds some extra, I guess, like type safety and things like that.
但它看起来很像 JavaScript。所以其中一些其他的东西，很难写一部分手写的 JavaScript，另一部分写 C++ 到 LLVM 到 JavaScript，你知道，那可能会变得混乱。相比之下，CoffeeScript 非常容易与手工编写的 JavaScript 并存。是的，绝对是。所以最后一个我们有的是 Clojure Tools。不要与 Clojure 混淆，那是一个 JavaScript 扩展。Clojure Tools（带 S）是……好吧，CLOS，closure tools，它是一种与 JavaScript 非常相似的语言，但它增加了一些额外的，比如类型安全之类的东西。
It's a statically typed language as opposed to JavaScript, which is dynamically typed. And the idea here is if you're doing something, if you're running like a big project, you have like hundreds of developers and there's all sorts of stuff going on, you really dynamically type languages can become an issue, can become a problem. They create bugs that are hard to find. You know, people can accidentally pass a function into something that expects a variable and you don't really have any you know compile time errors
它是一种静态类型语言，而不是 JavaScript 的动态类型。这里的想法是，如果你正在做某事，如果你正在运行一个大项目，你有数百名开发人员，而且有很多事情在发生，你真正动态类型的语言可能会成为一个问题。它们会产生难以发现的错误。你知道，人们可能会不小心把一个函数传递给期望变量的东西，而你没有任何……编译时错误。
because the system doesn't really know there's it can't make any assumptions because there's everything could be any type so closure sort of you know puts more restrictions on JavaScript with the idea being that you're going to use this for sort of enterprise application that you know you can more restrictions on JavaScript with the idea being that you're going to use this for sort of an enterprise application that, you know, you can use the extra time to make something that's more robust and less likely to fail. And Clojure code compiles into JavaScript. Nice, nice. Yeah, so what are, oh, go ahead. We're going to have to say... Oh, what are some of the strengths of JavaScript? Yes. So we talked about the fact that all the different browsers have JavaScript,
因为系统真的不知道，它不能做任何假设，因为一切都可能是任何类型。所以 Closure 某种程度上对 JavaScript 施加了更多限制，想法是你将把它用于某种企业级应用程序，你知道，你可以利用额外的时间来制作更健壮、更不容易失败的东西。而且 Clojure 代码编译成 JavaScript。不错，不错。是的，那么什么是……哦，请继续。我们不得不说……哦，JavaScript 的一些优势是什么？是的。所以我们谈到了所有不同的浏览器都有 JavaScript，
and we complained that they were different between them all. But the nice thing is that if you write in JavaScript, you know that the browser is going to have some support for it. Yeah, I mean, just to explain this in more detail, just to put a contrast on this, if you write your code in C, it's going to compile down to machine code, which of course your machine can understand because every machine has a machine code interpreter that is the CPU. If you use something like Python, the person on the other end, so the person who's running your code, the customer, needs to have Python installed. Or you can do some crazy hacks to sort of inject
我们抱怨它们之间有所不同。但好消息是，如果你用 JavaScript 编写，你知道浏览器会对其有某种支持。是的，我的意思是，为了更详细地解释这一点，为了形成对比，如果你用 C 编写代码，它会编译成机器码，你的机器当然可以理解，因为每台机器都有一个作为 CPU 的机器码解释器。如果你使用像 Python 这样的东西，另一端的人，也就是运行你的代码的人，客户，需要安装 Python。或者你可以做一些疯狂的黑客手段来注入……
the Python virtual machine onto their computer without them installing it. But I mean, those are hacks. But the thing about JavaScript is that everybody has the JavaScript interpreter. You don't have to tell them to go out and download it. It's already on the machine. Nice. Or like Flash, which doesn't come by default on a lot of installs. Yep. So another strength is JavaScript.
Python 虚拟机到他们的电脑上，而不需要他们安装。但我的意思是，那些是黑客手段。但 JavaScript 的事情是每个人都有 JavaScript 解释器。你不需要告诉他们去下载它。它已经在机器上了。不错。或者像 Flash，它在很多安装中不是默认提供的。没错。所以另一个优势是 JavaScript。
Now, JavaScript has something called JavaScript Object Notation or JSON. And JSON is actually used, it's similar to XML. It's a file format that's used in many languages. But it's particularly amenable to JavaScript because JSON consists of the basic primitives that JavaScript consists of. I mentioned before something's either an array an object floating point number or nothing and JSON in JSON something is also one of those four things so you can seamlessly go between Objects in JavaScript and this JSON format so you can
现在，JavaScript 有一种东西叫 JavaScript 对象表示法或 JSON。JSON 实际上被使用，它类似于 XML。它是一种在许多语言中使用的文件格式。但它特别适合 JavaScript，因为 JSON 由 JavaScript 的基本原语组成。我之前提到过，某物要么是数组、对象、浮点数或空，而在 JSON 中，某物也是这四种东西之一，所以你可以无缝地在 JavaScript 中的对象和这种 JSON 格式之间转换。所以你可以……
Say take your HTML DOM, which is a JavaScript object, convert it to JSON, and then send it to somebody else. Then he can convert it from JSON to a JavaScript object and continue manipulating it. Nice. Yeah, so there's also the ability to, JavaScript helps you not have to refresh a whole page
比如获取你的 HTML DOM，它是一个 JavaScript 对象，将其转换为 JSON，然后发送给其他人。然后他可以将其从 JSON 转换为 JavaScript 对象并继续操作它。不错。是的，还有能力，JavaScript 帮助你不需要刷新整个页面……
like back in the day everybody used to do. Whenever you would click something, pull down a menu and select something, the whole page would refresh. And things couldn't update. Once they were there, they were there. You couldn't get new news stories or new tweets to just pop up into your web page.
就像过去每个人都做的那样。每当你点击什么东西，下拉菜单并选择什么东西时，整个页面都会刷新。而且东西无法更新。一旦它们在那里，它们就在那里。你无法让新的新闻故事或新的推文直接弹出到你的网页中。
You would have to reload to see them. If you want a new mail you had to click the refresh button yep um and so ajax asynchronous java and xml did i get it right yep um has added that ability which was for the javascript to keep running and like jason talked about earlier kind of pull the server and say hey do you got anything new for me hey you got anything new for me and then act on it when something new does arrive that's right yeah so you're going back to the gmail example um there's a javascript thread which is constantly running in the in the background and constantly querying google and saying hey do you have any new mail and uh that's and so how
你必须重新加载才能看到它们。如果你想要新邮件，你必须点击刷新按钮。没错。所以 AJAX，异步 JavaScript 和 XML，我没说错吧？是的。增加了这种能力，即 JavaScript 继续运行，就像 Jason 之前谈到的那样，轮询服务器并说：“嘿，你有什么新东西给我吗？嘿，你有什么新东西给我吗？”然后当有新东西到达时采取行动。没错。是的，所以回到 Gmail 的例子，有一个 JavaScript 线程在后台不断运行，不断查询 Google 并说：“嘿，你有新邮件吗？”这就是它是如何……
it's doing that it's actually making a request so in other words there's a website that you can go to a real website in your browser and it would either return like just it'd either be blank or it would have a bunch of json in it which is like pretty unintelligible you know to humans but um python sorry javas JavaScript is constantly going to this website as if it was a real person typing in this URL. And whenever it gets something, whenever there's something to display, it's taking that data and saying, what is this? Oh, it's a new email, and then putting it on your screen. So JavaScript's able to pretend like it's a person and make additional requests and then put the results of those requests on the screen without refreshing the page
它在做那个，它实际上是在发出请求。换句话说，有一个网站，你可以去一个真实的网站，在你的浏览器中，它要么返回空白，要么包含一堆 JSON，这对人类来说是相当难以理解的。但是，Python……抱歉，JavaScript 不断地访问这个网站，就好像它是一个真人在输入这个 URL。每当它得到什么东西，每当有东西要显示时，它就会获取该数据并说：“这是什么？哦，这是一封新邮件”，然后将其放在你的屏幕上。所以 JavaScript 能够假装它是一个人，发出额外的请求，然后将这些请求的结果放在屏幕上，而无需刷新页面。
yep so uh yeah another oh go ahead no we keep doing this i know we're just you know ever since patrick moved to the valley we've just been on sync i think that's what it is i think you have to move back now we just shorten that delay between us that just enough that now we can interrupt each other fantastic so javascript you know the people who designed javascript they knew that well tabbed browsers weren't around but you know multiple browser windows were around and people knew that you would have more than one website open at a time. And so, and they also knew that websites had to be responsive and that was key to the user experience. I mean, if the server is busy doing something and your browser locks up, I mean,
没错。所以……是的，另一个……哦，请继续。不，我们一直在这样做。我知道，自从 Patrick 搬到硅谷以来，我们就一直不同步，我想这就是原因。我想你得搬回来了。我们只是缩短了我们之间的延迟，刚好足够现在我们可以互相打断了。太棒了。所以 JavaScript，你知道，设计 JavaScript 的人，他们知道，虽然标签式浏览器还没有出现，但多浏览器窗口已经存在了，人们知道你一次会打开不止一个网站。所以，他们也知道网站必须是响应式的，这对用户体验至关重要。我的意思是，如果服务器忙于做某事而你的浏览器锁死了，我的意思是……
that's a really bad user experience. You know, often, you know, if you're using Photoshop and you're doing some really complicated task and so you just get the bar that slowly goes across the screen, that's okay because you expect that doing some crazy Fourier transform or doing some magic eraser or something in Photoshop is going to take a while. And so you expect that. But on the Internet, the expectation is that things would be instant or as close to instant as possible. And so to sort of obfuscate all of the time that goes into making requests, waiting for the server, JavaScript is asynchronous, which we mentioned back in the Objective-C episode. It's designed for you to be able to say, hey, I need some data, but I don't want to wait for it. Whenever you have it, let me know. But in the meantime, I'm going to keep running.
那是一个非常糟糕的用户体验。你知道，通常，如果你在使用 Photoshop，并且你在做一些非常复杂的任务，所以你只是得到了那个在屏幕上缓慢移动的进度条，那没关系，因为你期望做一些疯狂的傅里叶变换或在 Photoshop 中做一些魔术橡皮擦之类的东西需要一段时间。所以你期望那样。但在互联网上，期望是事情应该是即时的，或者尽可能接近即时。所以为了掩盖所有用于发出请求、等待服务器的时间，JavaScript 是异步的，我们在 Objective-C 那一集提到过。它被设计成让你能够说：“嘿，我需要一些数据，但我不想等待它。无论你什么时候有，告诉我。但在此期间，我将继续运行。”
And so JavaScript is designed from the ground up to be asynchronous. And that's one of its biggest strengths. That's one of the reasons why Node.js is so popular. The server could get a request from a client and say, hey, go process this. But I don't want to wait for that. I have more clients that I need to talk to. And so asynchronous languages actually make for great web servers. But they also make for really great anything.
所以 JavaScript 从底层设计就是异步的。这是它最大的优势之一。这也是 Node.js 如此受欢迎的原因之一。服务器可以从客户端获取请求并说：“嘿，去处理这个。但我不想等待那个。我有更多的客户端需要交谈。”所以异步语言实际上造就了伟大的 Web 服务器。但它们也造就了伟大的任何东西。
So some of the issues, we already alluded to this one many, many times, but the fact that JavaScript doesn't have a standard implementation and exact definition across all the browsers so you got to handle that somehow either by doing kind of if statements in your code all over or using a library that tries to handle it from you or handle it for you and that's an issue that's hopefully will get better one day but i'm not going to hold my breath yeah i mean even today if you look at websites in internet explorer and you look at them in chrome or firefox you'll see different there's either a different visual style or you know there's some different functionality it's just it's it's close to impossible or at least it's extremely difficult
所以一些问题，我们已经多次提到过这一点，但事实是 JavaScript 在所有浏览器中没有标准的实现和精确的定义，所以你必须以某种方式处理它，要么在你的代码中到处写 if 语句，要么使用一个试图为你处理它的库，这是一个希望有一天会好转的问题，但我不会屏住呼吸。是的，我的意思是，即使在今天，如果你在 Internet Explorer 中查看网站，然后在 Chrome 或 Firefox 中查看它们，你会看到不同之处。要么是不同的视觉风格，要么是某些不同的功能，这简直是……几乎不可能，或者至少极其困难……
to get things to behave the same and that's why you end up with some really crazy hacks. Like I saw one hack where they got a rounded rectangle by creating a bunch of like really tiny like one pixel high rectangles. And they just by layering a bunch of these like a cake, they were able to create sort of like this rounded shape on the top and the bottom of the rectangle and so it's just you get these crazy hacks because people do crazy stuff like that though because it makes their website stand out different than everybody else's right and you know you think about the process of a website is you have an artist who's using something like photoshop where he can do whatever he wants with those pixels. And he comes up with a mock of like, this is how I want it to look.
让事情表现得一样，这就是为什么你最终会得到一些非常疯狂的黑客手段。比如我看到一个黑客手段，他们通过创建一堆像一像素高的小矩形来获得圆角矩形。他们只是通过像蛋糕一样堆叠一堆这些东西，他们能够创建某种像矩形顶部和底部的这种圆形形状，所以你只是得到这些疯狂的黑客手段，因为人们做这种疯狂的事情，因为这让他们的网站看起来与众不同，对吧？而且你知道，你考虑网站的过程是，你有一个艺术家，他正在使用像 Photoshop 这样的东西，他可以用那些像素做任何他想做的事。他想出了一个模型，比如：“这就是我想要它看起来的样子。”
This is my vision. And this is sort of the best user experience. And he kind of has the expectation that you can sort of make this a reality. And so often, you know, the programmer has the burden of sort of taking this image that someone made in Photoshop and creating a website that sort of conforms to this image. And so in trying to accomplish that, yeah, you end up with some really crazy stuff. Another thing is that it can be hard with some of this stuff that you're basically going to a website, downloading some code, and running it on
这是我的愿景。这是某种最好的用户体验。他有一种期望，即你可以某种程度上使这成为现实。所以通常，你知道，程序员有某种负担，要获取某人在 Photoshop 中制作的这张图像，并创建一个某种程度上符合这张图像的网站。所以为了实现这一点，是的，你最终会得到一些非常疯狂的东西。另一件事是，使用一些你基本上是去一个网站，下载一些代码，并在……上运行它的东西可能会很困难。
your computer yep but that's exactly what hackers want to be able to do yeah that's just have you download code and run it on your computer because in most of the time when that happens it's a win for the hacker they win that um once code is executed on your computer they can make that code be whatever they want and they win um but the javascript the challenge is you got to be able to do that but limit it and so you can't let it do which kind of will play into the our next point but that you can't let it do certain things because else people would make it do bad things so you have to very much limit what it has access to what it's allowed to do what it's not allowed to, what it's not allowed to do, how it can behave. Right. Like just to put it in perspective, HTML5 adds local files to JavaScript. So up until now,
你的电脑。没错，但这正是黑客想要能够做的事情。是的，就是让你下载代码并在你的电脑上运行它，因为在大多数情况下，当这种情况发生时，这对黑客来说是一场胜利。他们赢了。一旦代码在你的电脑上执行，他们就可以让该代码成为他们想要的任何东西，他们就赢了。但是 JavaScript 的挑战是，你必须能够做到这一点，但要限制它。所以你不能让它做……这有点会影响我们的下一点，但你不能让它做某些事情，因为否则人们会用它做坏事。所以你必须非常限制它能访问什么，它被允许做什么，它不被允许做什么，它不被允许做什么，它如何表现。对。就像为了说明问题，HTML5 向 JavaScript 添加了本地文件。所以直到现在，
you haven't been able to create a file on the client's computer. So think about that. I mean, you know, the very first thing you learn when you learn a language is reading and writing to a file. Like one of the very first things is, you know, you create a file, hello world.txt, and you read all the lines from it or something like that. But, you know, up until now, you haven't been able to create or delete files in JavaScript. And it's because of what Patrick's saying. You know, someone else is running code on your computer. And so if you go to some malicious website maybe they create a ton of files or they read your whole hard drive or something like that
你还不能在客户端的电脑上创建文件。所以想想看。我的意思是，你知道，当你学习一门语言时，你学到的第一件事就是读写文件。就像最初的事情之一是，你知道，你创建一个文件，hello world.txt，然后你从它读取所有行之类的。但是，你知道，直到现在，你还不能在 JavaScript 中创建或删除文件。这是因为 Patrick 所说的。其他人正在你的电脑上运行代码。所以如果你去某个恶意网站，也许他们会创建一堆文件，或者他们会读取你的整个硬盘之类的。
so now with html5 there's i believe you know you can you first of all you can't access the hard drive you can only access like one folder on the drive and then in that folder i think you can only create five megabytes worth of files per session so you know they have all these restrictions now and browsers have become more sophisticated so that you can you know do things like that but but yeah you can't there's a lot of things that you can't do in javascript because of that reason yep so what are some of the things you can't do in javascript do you know any you have any in mind any things you can't do you can't access a microphone yeah i mean that's i think
所以现在有了 HTML5，我相信，你知道，你首先不能访问硬盘，你只能访问驱动器上的一个文件夹，然后在那个文件夹中，我想你每个会话只能创建 5 兆字节的文件。所以，你知道，他们现在有所有这些限制，浏览器变得更加复杂，这样你就可以，你知道，做那样的事情。但但是的，你不能……因为那个原因，有很多事情你不能在 JavaScript 中做。没错。所以 JavaScript 中有哪些你不能做的事情？你知道任何吗？你有什么想到的吗？任何你不能做的事情？你不能访问麦克风。是的，我的意思是，我认为……
that's huge right i mean look at um uh what was i thinking there's uh so for instance skype skype can't run in just a website they'd have have to use Flash. Yeah, like Google Hangouts. Google Hangouts is sort of a thing where you can chat with different people online. But to do that, you have to download and install and use somebody's graphics processor, which you can't use it directly. But in theory, somebody else could detect what you're doing and decide to run that code on the GPU if they wanted. Right. So there is, and to be completely fair, there's WebGL, which doesn't let you write code to access access the GPU but does let you you know draw triangles and things like that using the GPU so you know HTML5 has unlimited GPU accessibility but yeah and the browser also will do things like use
那很重要，对吧？我的意思是，看看……我在想什么？有……比如 Skype，Skype 不能只在网站上运行，他们必须使用 Flash。是的，像 Google Hangouts。Google Hangouts 是一种你可以与在线不同的人聊天的事情。但要做到这一点，你必须下载并安装并使用某人的图形处理器，你不能直接使用它。但在理论上，其他人可以检测到你在做什么，并决定在 GPU 上运行该代码（如果他们想的话）。对。所以有，为了完全公平，有 WebGL，它不允许你编写代码来访问 GPU，但确实让你，你知道，使用 GPU 绘制三角形之类的东西。所以，你知道，HTML5 有无限的 GPU 可访问性，但是的，浏览器也会做一些事情，比如使用……
the GPU to help rescale pictures and things like that but that's sort of outside of control that you have as a JavaScript programmer. You don't know whether or not that's going to happen. Yeah, exactly. So yeah, I mean, really, if you have some kind of custom hardware, if it's a webcam, a microphone, pretty much anything.
GPU 来帮助调整图片大小之类的，但这超出了你作为 JavaScript 程序员的控制范围。你不知道那是否会发生。是的，完全正确。所以是的，我的意思是，真的，如果你有某种定制硬件，如果是网络摄像头、麦克风，几乎任何东西。
I mean, the volume on your speakers. I don't know, I'm just looking around. You have pretty much no hardware. My TV. Yeah, my USB-powered robot that cleans the floor. An airplane. Yeah, your RC plane. JavaScript can't control any of these,
我的意思是，扬声器的音量。我不知道，我只是四处看看。你几乎没有任何硬件。我的电视。是的，我的 USB 供电的清洁地板的机器人。一架飞机。是的，你的遥控飞机。 JavaScript 无法控制任何这些，
and this is because you don't want to go to some website like crazyjoe.com, and then all of a sudden your printer starts printing, right? Well, it depends on what it's printing. If it's printing something awesome maybe I do if it's a coupon to Crazy Joe's yeah
这是因为你不想去某个像 crazyjoe.com 这样的网站，然后突然你的打印机开始打印，对吧？好吧，这取决于它在打印什么。如果它在打印一些很棒的东西，也许我想要，如果它是 Crazy Joe's 的优惠券，是的……
maybe I'd want that alright alright man well I think that was good that was good good talk about JavaScript
也许我想要那个。好吧，好吧，伙计，嗯，我认为那很好，那很好，关于 JavaScript 的好谈话。
congratulations making it through 10 episodes man pat yourself on the back yeah you too man definitely this is a this is a milestone
祝贺你完成了 10 集，伙计，拍拍自己的背。是的，你也是，伙计，绝对的，这是一个里程碑。
I think that every episode has been really has been really awesome and i hope that the people out there uh feel the same way we do that we've really been able to sort of deliver a lot of content with some good flavor yeah i've definitely enjoyed doing all of these and hearing from you guys out there and saying that you know you enjoy the show as well and that's definitely encouraging definitely encouraging and keeps us doing this and excited about doing it. We have a lot of friends now on our Google Plus account of Programming Throwdown. I see every so often, I keep seeing people in there doing stuff.
我认为每一集都非常非常棒，我希望外面的人……感觉和我们一样，我们真的能够某种程度上提供大量带有良好风味的内容。是的，我绝对喜欢做所有这些，并听到你们的声音，说你知道，你们也喜欢这个节目，这绝对是令人鼓舞的，绝对是令人鼓舞的，并让我们继续这样做，并对做这件事感到兴奋。我们现在在我们的 Programming Throwdown 的 Google Plus 账户上有很多朋友。我时不时地看到，我一直看到人们在那里做事情。
We're getting a couple more iTunes reviews we've gotten. So that's pretty awesome. Keep doing that. Keep up that work. Help us increase our ranking on iTunes. Yeah, so just so everybody knows, we have a blog, programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com. We also have an email address, programmingthrowdown at gmail.com.
我们得到了更多的 iTunes 评论。所以这太棒了。继续这样做。保持那种工作。帮助我们提高我们在 iTunes 上的排名。是的，所以为了让每个人都知道，我们有一个博客，programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com。我们还有一个电子邮件地址，programmingthrowdown@gmail.com。
So you can email us any suggestions for new languages that you want to see or particular topics or just give us comments and feedback. We're also on iTunes. You can rate us on iTunes. And we're now on G+. So add us to your circles. Yeah, that's cool.
所以你可以给我们发电子邮件，提出任何你想要看到的新语言的建议，或者特定的主题，或者只是给我们评论和反馈。我们也在 iTunes 上。你可以在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们现在在 G+ 上。所以把我们加到你的圈子里。是的，那很酷。
Also, we should mention that oh I completely just lost my train of thought oh we need to make sure we are on android marketplace as well or whatever the android download too we need to do that somebody mentioned that to me one of our fans oh I don't know what are you talking about android download there's a
另外，我们应该提到，哦，我完全失去了思路，哦，我们需要确保我们也在 Android 市场或任何 Android 下载上，我们也需要这样做，有人向我提到了这一点，我们的粉丝之一。哦，我不知道你在说什么 Android 下载，有一个……
they said there's an android podcast oh really like catcher oh I didn't know that yeah oh yeah we'll learn something new every day this person that one of the fans was telling me that that they tried to find us on their android phone and whatever app they were using they couldn't find us on it so oh yeah we'll have to check into that okay anyway sorry yeah well you'll find us on there too once we fix it all right well thanks for listening in and uh like always uh make sure to leave us some feedback yeah definitely have a good one guys and gals the intro music is axo
他们说有一个 Android 播客。哦，真的吗？像 Catcher？我不知道。是的，哦，是的，我们每天都会学到新东西。这个粉丝告诉我说，他们试图在他们的 Android 手机上找到我们，无论他们使用什么应用程序，他们都找不到我们，所以……哦，是的，我们得去查查那个。好吧，无论如何，抱歉。是的，好吧，一旦我们修复它，你也会在那里找到我们。好吧，感谢收听，像往常一样，确保给我们留下一些反馈。是的，绝对的，祝你们好运，伙计们和女士们。片头音乐是 Axo……
by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由 Biner Pilot 创作。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。